This episode is brought to you by Lloyd's business and commercial banking. One of the great things about finance is that it may result in you having to pay tax. And this was a constant grumble in Anglo-Saxon England, which was the most heavily taxed country in the whole of Christendom. And just when the Anglo-Saxons thought it couldn't get any worse, they got conquered by King Canute. And Canute imposed a tax rate that was effectively... 100%. Yeah, well, that was one very big change, Tom, but another tax change is upon us. And this is the advent of making tax digital for income tax. And if you're at all concerned about it, this is where Lloyd's come in, because they're here to help make that change much simpler
本期节目由劳埃德商业银行赞助播出。金融的一大妙处在于，它可能会让你不得不纳税。这在盎格鲁-撒克逊时期的英格兰是一个永恒的抱怨，当时它是整个基督教世界中税负最重的国家。就在盎格鲁-撒克逊人以为情况不会再糟的时候，他们被克努特国王征服了。克努特征收的税率实际上达到了……100%。是的，汤姆，那是一个巨大的变化，但现在我们又面临另一项税务变革。这就是针对所得税的“税收数字化”时代的到来。如果你对此有任何顾虑，劳埃德银行可以为你提供帮助，因为他们致力于让这一转变变得更加简单。
for you with a useful HMRC-recognised accounting tool that will help you stay in line with all the making tax digital requirements. And the brilliant thing about this is, is that it is free for Lloyd's business account customers. So when it is time to digitize your income tax, you can bank on Lloyd's. Search Lloyd's business accounts to find out more. Staples Preferred Business Membership, built for busy business owners,
他们为你提供了一款实用的、经英国税务海关总署（HMRC）认可的会计工具，将帮助你符合所有税收数字化的要求。最棒的是，对于劳埃德商业账户客户，这款工具是免费的。所以，当需要将你的所得税数字化时，你可以信赖劳埃德银行。搜索“劳埃德商业账户”了解更多信息。史泰博（Staples）优选商业会员，专为忙碌的企业主打造，
because you've got bigger things to think about. With Staples preferred, get free delivery, no minimums. Staples Preferred unlocks up to 3% back. Plus 10% savings on print and exclusive wireless offers. One less thing on your plate. Actually, a lot less. Visit staples.ca slash preferred. That was easy.
因为你有更重要的事情要考虑。加入史泰博优选，享受免费送货，无最低消费限制。史泰博优选最高可返现3%。此外，打印服务可节省10%，并享有独家无线产品优惠。让你少操一份心。实际上，是少操很多心。访问 staples.ca/preferred。就是这么简单。
Hey y'all, it's Kelly Clarkson with Wayfair. Ever order furniture online and wonder what if? Like, what if it doesn't hold up? That sofa was four days old. You should have ordered from Wayfair. With Wayfair, there's no what if. Just style you love and quality you can trust. Visit Wayfair.ca.
大家好，我是凯莉·克拉克森，代表Wayfair为您服务。有没有在网上订购过家具，然后心想“万一呢”？比如，万一质量不好怎么办？那张沙发才用了四天。你当时就应该在Wayfair订购。在Wayfair，没有“万一”。只有你喜欢的风格和值得信赖的品质。访问 Wayfair.ca。
Wayfair, every style, every house. home. So that was a song originally entitled The Defense of Fort McHenry and it was written by a guy called Francis Scott Key in September 1814 and it is probably better known as the Star Spangled Banner. And Dominic, what better way to kick off our series marking the 2026 football or if you're in America soccer World Cup held in the United States in Mexico and Canada, which starts this Thursday and it will be ending in just over a month in New York. So Dominic, what we've done with this series, we have picked six competing nations in this World Cup, haven't we, whose national anthems have a fascinating backstory,
Wayfair，各种风格，各种家居。好的，刚才那首歌原名《保卫麦克亨利堡》，由弗朗西斯·斯科特·基在1814年9月创作，它可能更广为人知的名字是《星条旗》。多米尼克，有什么比这更好的方式来开启我们的系列节目呢？我们是为了纪念2026年足球世界杯（如果你在美国，也可以叫它英式足球世界杯），该赛事将在美国、墨西哥和加拿大举行，本周四开幕，一个多月后在纽约结束。多米尼克，在这个系列中，我们挑选了六个参加本届世界杯的国家，它们的国歌都有着迷人的背景故事，
tell us all kinds of things about the countries that they serve as a national anthem, and all kinds of fabulous characters in them and lots of great myths to be busted. We love Busting a Myth. We love Busting a Myth. So on Thursday, we are going to be looking at England and Scotland. And then next week, we're going to be looking at Germany and the Netherlands. And in our third week, we're going to be looking at Brazil and then, last of all, South Africa. But fittingly, because it is the host nation, because of its prominence in sport, because it is famously the most difficult anthem actually to sing, we are going to be starting with the Star Spangled Banner.
向我们讲述了关于这些国家作为国歌的各种信息，其中包含了各种精彩的人物和许多需要被打破的伟大神话。我们喜欢打破神话。我们喜欢打破神话。所以周四，我们将关注英格兰和苏格兰。下周，我们将关注德国和荷兰。第三周，我们将关注巴西，最后是南非。但恰如其分的是，因为它是东道国，因为它在体育界的突出地位，也因为它确实是公认最难唱的国歌，我们将从《星条旗》开始。
Yes. So, hello everybody. A very recognisable anthem. It's been reinterpreted very controversially at times by Jose Feliciano, by Jimmy Hendrix, by Whitney Houston, and by Borat Sagdeev. It played a central role, of course, in the Black Lives Matter protests in the late 2010s and in 2020. So it was during the playing of the Star-Spangled banner that the San Francisco 49ers quarterback, Colin Kaepernick, first took the knee in 2016, and we'll be talking about that bit later. There have actually always been people who don't like this anthem, Americans who don't like it.
是的。那么，大家好。这是一首非常耳熟能详的国歌。它曾被何塞·费利西亚诺、吉米·亨德里克斯、惠特尼·休斯顿和波拉特·萨格耶夫以极具争议的方式重新演绎。当然，它在2010年代末和2020年的“黑人的命也是命”抗议活动中发挥了核心作用。正是在演奏《星条旗》期间，旧金山49人队的四分卫科林·卡佩尼克在2016年首次单膝下跪，我们稍后会讨论这一点。实际上，一直都有不喜欢这首国歌的人，即不喜欢它的美国人。
And there have been lots of alternative versions as Americans have tried to adapt it to their own political causes. So again, we'll talk about that a little bit later. But first of all, I think it would be fun to start off with the historical moment that the anthem is all about. So this is the British attack on Fort McHenry, which is just off Baltimore in Maryland in September 1814. And that means that we will be talking about a war that I think is genuinely never spoken about from one year to the next in Britain. Except the king did mention it, didn't he, in his recent speech, made a very good joke about it. But he didn't say that in Britain, he said it in the United States. So on British soil, I don't think it has ever mentioned.
而且有很多替代版本，因为美国人试图将其改编以适应他们自己的政治诉求。所以，我们稍后会再讨论这一点。但首先，我认为从这首国歌所涉及的历史时刻开始会很有趣。这就是1814年9月英国对马里兰州巴尔的摩附近的麦克亨利堡的袭击。这意味着我们将讨论一场我认为在英国几乎从未被提及的战争。除了国王在最近的演讲中确实提到了它，还开了一个很好的玩笑。但他不是在英国说的，而是在美国说的。所以，在英国本土，我认为它从未被提及。
That is true. This is the war of 1812. And even for American listeners, I think, would have to concede that this war is very obscure. As in fact, reading an American historian about it. And he said, basically we skim over this in schools. No one really talks about it. No one understands what it was about or what the point of it was. Partly, I think, because it's a draw.
确实如此。这就是1812年战争。即使对于美国听众来说，我认为也不得不承认这场战争非常晦涩。事实上，读一位美国历史学家的著作时，他说，基本上我们在学校里对这段历史一笔带过。没有人真正谈论它。没有人理解它是关于什么的，或者它的意义何在。部分原因我认为是因为它是一场平局。
So no one really enjoys. You know, no one really revels in it. I think there's been a certain degree of reveling on this podcast, hasn't there? Because it does see the British burn down the White House. It does. Yeah, one of the great moments in history. And we will be alluding to that today. So it's eclipsed in America, I think, by the independence struggle, the tax revolt.
所以没有人真正享受它。你知道，没有人真正沉浸其中。我认为在这个播客中有一种沉浸感，不是吗？因为它确实见证了英国人烧毁白宫。确实。是的，这是历史上伟大的时刻之一。我们今天会提到这一点。所以，我认为在美国，它被独立战争和税收反抗所掩盖了。
and it's eclipsed in Britain by the world war against Napoleonic France. And it's basically a sequel to the American War of Independence and an offshoot of the Napoleonic Wars. And to cut a very long story short, this war, the War of 1812, broke out that summer for four reasons. So first of all, the Madison administration, so this is, I think, the fourth president of the United States, James Madison, not a terribly colorful or well-known president.
而在英国，它被反对拿破仑法国的世界大战所掩盖。它基本上是美国独立战争的续集，也是拿破仑战争的分支。长话短说，这场1812年战争在那年夏天爆发，原因有四。首先，麦迪逊政府，也就是我认为的美国第四任总统詹姆斯·麦迪逊，他不是一位特别引人注目或广为人知的总统。
he's chafing at Britain's trade embargo against Napoleonic France. And the Americans say, come on, why are we subject to this trade embargo? We want to be able to trade freely. We don't want the Royal Navy, you know, seizing our ships. Reason number two, they don't want the Royal Navy pressing American seamen into the Royal Navy. So when the Royal Navy, you know, seize an American ship, they will take some of the Americans and force them to work on the British ship. People are sick of that.
他对英国针对拿破仑法国的贸易禁运感到恼火。美国人说，得了吧，为什么我们要受这个贸易禁运的限制？我们想要自由贸易。我们不希望皇家海军扣押我们的船只。第二个原因，他们不希望皇家海军强征美国海员加入皇家海军。所以当皇家海军扣押一艘美国船只时，他们会带走一些美国人，强迫他们在英国船上工作。人们对此感到厌倦。
Number three, the Madison administration, have expanded. conscientist ambitions. So they think, or the Brits are just distracted by what's going on in Europe, we can seize upper and lower Canada. So that's sort of Ontario country. And that's something they've been kind of angling to do since the War of Independence, isn't it? Exactly, they have. They think they've got unfinished business, basically. They want to take what becomes Canada. And it kind of rumbles on, doesn't it? Because there's that whole thing with a windmill. The windmill. We did that on a bonus episode. Great Canadian victory. And the Americans also think There are lots of sort of Native American Indian confederations that stand in the way of Westwood expansion that are allied to the British.
第三，麦迪逊政府有扩张主义的野心。所以他们认为，或者说英国人只是被欧洲发生的事情分散了注意力，我们可以夺取上加拿大和下加拿大。也就是安大略地区。这正是他们自独立战争以来一直想做的事情，不是吗？没错，他们确实想做。他们认为自己还有未竟的事业，基本上。他们想夺取后来成为加拿大的土地。这事儿一直拖着，不是吗？因为还有那个关于风车的事情。风车。我们在奖励剧集中讲过。伟大的加拿大胜利。美国人还认为，有许多美洲原住民印第安联盟阻碍了向西扩张，他们与英国结盟。
Let's seize the opportunity to knock them out too. And finally, they think, you know, nothing builds a nation more than a war, a successful war. Let's have a second war of independence. We've had a lot of internal divisions recently. We can all rally around the flag? And Dominic, can I just ask, because the flag is going to be quite important in this story. At this point, it is 15 stars and 15 stripes. Exactly right.
让我们抓住机会把他们也干掉。最后，他们认为，你知道，没有什么比一场战争，一场成功的战争更能建立一个国家了。让我们进行第二次独立战争吧。我们最近有很多内部纷争。我们可以团结在旗帜下吗？多米尼克，我能问一下吗，因为旗帜在这个故事中会很重要。此时，它是15颗星和15条纹。完全正确。
exactly. If you take the first year or so of the war, the Americans are on the attack, the British are on the defensive, the Americans launched their invasion of Upper and Lower Canada, and they think it's going to be a walkover. Thomas Jefferson, not a great friend of the rest of its history, says that it's the acquisition of Canada as far as the neighbourhood of Quebec, will be a mere matter of marching. Was he ever right about anything? Sadly not. Another war hawk, Henry Clay, said to Congress, you need, you even need to send a proper army, just send the content. Kentucky militia and they will lay Montreal and Upper Canada at your feet. And I'm very happy to say, especially happy on behalf of our Canadian listeners, that this is
完全正确。如果你看战争的第一年左右，美国人处于进攻状态，英国人处于防御状态，美国人发动了对上加拿大和下加拿大的入侵，他们认为这将是一场轻松的胜利。托马斯·杰斐逊，不是英国历史的好朋友，他说夺取加拿大直到魁北克附近，将仅仅是行军的问题。他什么时候对过吗？遗憾的是没有。另一位鹰派人物亨利·克莱对国会说，你甚至不需要派遣正规军，只需派遣肯塔基民兵，他们就会把蒙特利尔和上加拿大放在你的脚下。我很高兴地说，尤其是代表我们的加拿大听众感到高兴的是，这
not true at all, because the invasions of Canada are complete and utter failure and the British actually end up occupying parts of the United States, parts of Michigan and Maine. And this is, of course, a foundational moment in Canadian identity. So the one place where people do talk about the War of 1812 is in Canada because it's the the central distinctive moment that marks them out, I think. And Dominic, of course, Canada is co-hosting with the United States and Mexico, this World Cup. And so this is another very important reason why we're doing this particular topic, isn't it? It's for our Canadian listeners.
根本不是真的，因为对加拿大的入侵是彻底的失败，英国人最终实际上占领了美国的部分地区，密歇根州和缅因州的部分地区。这当然是加拿大身份认同的一个奠基时刻。所以人们确实谈论1812年战争的唯一地方是在加拿大，因为这是我认为标志着他们的核心独特时刻。多米尼克，当然，加拿大正在与美国和墨西哥共同主办这届世界杯。所以这是我们做这个特定主题的另一个非常重要的原因，不是吗？这是为了我们的加拿大听众。
This is really a Canadian story. Let them know we love them. Yeah, exactly. The following year, 1813, the British launched a naval offensive of their own, the Chesapeake Bay campaign. And basically the plan is to quote Rear Admiral George Coburn, who's in charge of it, we're going to lay waste to the shore, we're going to lay waste to all these towns within this vast bay, including the capital in Washington, D.C., because we want to cripple America's commerce across the Atlantic, and that will turn public opinion in America against the war. And at first, the British do this in a sort of half-hearted way, but then by 1814, Napoleon has been beaten. So he's abdicated for the first time, and he's been sent off to Elba.
这确实是一个加拿大的故事。让他们知道我们爱他们。是的，完全正确。第二年，1813年，英国人发起了他们自己的海军攻势，即切萨皮克湾战役。基本上计划是引用负责此事的乔治·科伯恩海军少将的话，我们要摧毁海岸，我们要摧毁这个巨大海湾内的所有城镇，包括首都华盛顿特区，因为我们要削弱美国在大西洋的商业，这将使美国的公众舆论反对战争。起初，英国人以一种半心半意的方式这样做，但到了1814年，拿破仑已经被击败了。所以他第一次退位，被送到了厄尔巴岛。
And so the British say, well, the Americans are still going, bizarrely. So why don't we divert resources now to knock them out of the war? So let's set the scene. It's the summer of 1814, and the British are advancing up their Potomac River from the coast. They're heading towards Alexandria and Washington, D.C. And this is the context for Coburn, the Rear Admiral and Major General Robbie Ross to carry out one of the most intrepid and inspiring operations in world history, An operation I know our American listeners love hearing about, which is the occupation of Washington and the burning down of the US capital and the White House.
所以英国人说，好吧，奇怪的是美国人还在继续。那么我们为什么不转移资源现在把他们踢出战争呢？让我们设定场景。那是1814年的夏天，英国人正从海岸沿波托马克河推进。他们正前往亚历山大和华盛顿特区。这就是科伯恩海军少将和罗比·罗斯少将进行世界历史上最勇敢和鼓舞人心的行动之一的背景，我知道我们的美国听众喜欢听到的行动，即占领华盛顿并烧毁美国国会大厦和白宫。
Robbie Ross is an Irishman, isn't he? So it's a reminder of Anglo-Irish operations. Yeah. Ireland and Great Britain standing shoulders to shoulder against a common foe. I think that's how we like to see it. Harwarming. So they burn the White House, they eat Dolly Madison's dinner. And four days later, they are heading for their next target, which is Baltimore. Baltimore, Maryland at this point is I think something like the third biggest city in the United States. It's a really important trading, harbour and all of that. And they are in great spirits, the British. They've been drinking a lot, unsurprisingly, and they've been helping themselves to what they see as long overdue tax returns from the American rebels. And sad to say, there's a local busybody who's called Dr. Beans, Dr. William Beans, and he looks,
罗比·罗斯是个爱尔兰人，对吧？所以这是对英爱联合行动的提醒。是的。爱尔兰和英国肩并肩对抗共同的敌人。我想这就是我们喜欢看到的方式。暖心。所以他们烧毁了白宫，吃了多莉·麦迪逊的晚餐。四天后，他们正前往下一个目标，即巴尔的摩。巴尔的摩，马里兰州在这一点上我认为是美国第三大城市。它是一个非常重要的贸易港口等等。他们精神饱满，英国人。他们喝了很多酒，不出所料，他们一直在拿他们认为是美国叛军拖欠已久的税款。遗憾的是，有一个当地的爱管闲事的人叫比恩斯医生，威廉·比恩斯医生，他看起来，
lives in rural Maryland, and he tries to stop the British from basically looting and pillaging. We're not looting and pillaging. You just said that collecting tax arrears. That was just me putting myself in Dr. Beans's head. I don't agree with him. He's obviously a terrible man. Oh, thank God I'm on hand to provide the objectivity that a good history podcast should provide. So quite rightly, our brave lads arrested this bloke Beans and they took him down the river towards Baltimore. And some of his friends wanted to petition the British for Dr. Beans' release. This was a very common practice during the war. He would basically go under flag of truce and say, please, can we have a so-and-so back? And his friends decide to get a go-between,
住在马里兰州农村，他试图阻止英国人基本上进行抢劫和掠夺。我们不是在抢劫和掠夺。你刚才说那是征收拖欠的税款。那只是我把自己放在比恩斯医生的脑子里。我不同意他的观点。他显然是个糟糕的人。哦，谢天谢地，我在场提供一个好的历史播客应该提供的客观性。所以很正确，我们勇敢的小伙子逮捕了这个叫比恩斯的家伙，他们把他带下河向巴尔的摩方向。他的一些朋友想向英国人请愿释放比恩斯医生。这在战争期间是一种非常普遍的做法。他基本上会打着休战旗去说，请问我们能把某某人带回来吗？他的朋友们决定找一个中间人，
and the go-between in question is a lawyer called Francis Scott Key, who we mentioned right at the start of this show. We did indeed, so he's the author of the anthem. Now, American listeners, of course, will recognize his name, but they might not know loads about him. Key was born in 1779 to a fairly well-of-family in Maryland. His father had been in George. George Washington's rebel army. He'd been a judge. Francis Scott Key grew up in the family plantation. So he's from a slave-owning family.
而这个中间人是一位名叫弗朗西斯·斯科特·基的律师，我们在节目开始时提到过他。我们确实提到了，所以他是国歌的作者。现在，美国听众当然会认出他的名字，但他们可能对他了解不多。基出生于1779年，来自马里兰州一个相当富裕的家庭。他的父亲曾在乔治·华盛顿的叛军军队中服役。他曾是一名法官。弗朗西斯·斯科特·基在家庭种植园长大。所以他来自一个蓄奴家庭。
He comes from a slave-owning family, which will be important later on. He was a well-known lawyer. He had 11 children, which I think seems a lot. He lives with his wife and 11 children in Georgetown. He does various big trials. He speaks before the Supreme Court. He's quite a well-known person. And the fact that he is a slave owner, Tom,
他来自一个蓄奴家庭，这在以后会很重要。他是一位著名的律师。他有11个孩子，我认为这很多。他和他的妻子以及11个孩子住在乔治城。他处理过各种大案。他在最高法院发言。他是一个相当有名的人。而他是一个奴隶主的事实，汤姆，
I'm glad to you've flagged it because it is going to make this anthem controversial later on, so we'll come to that. Anyway, the 2nd of September 1814, Key writes to his mother and he says, I'm going in the morning to Baltimore to proceed in a flag vessel to General Ross. Old Dr. Beans of Marlborough is taken prisoner by the enemy. And some of his friends have urged me to go and get him out and to procure his release. I don't know where he is, but I'll do my best. So he goes off to Baltimore. He finds the local United States agent who deals a prisoners of war, they rent a ship
我很高兴你指出了这一点，因为它会让这首国歌在以后引起争议，所以我们稍后会谈到这一点。总之，1814年9月2日，基写信给他的母亲，他说，我明天早上要去巴尔的摩，乘坐一艘休战船前往罗斯将军那里。马尔伯勒的老比恩斯医生被敌人俘虏了。他的一些朋友敦促我去把他救出来，并促成他的释放。我不知道他在哪里，但我会尽我所能。所以他去了巴尔的摩。他找到了处理战俘的当地美国代理人，他们租了一艘船
and they sail off towards Chesapeake Bay and they're looking for the British fleet because they think that's where this Blake Beans is being held. And on the 7th of September, they find HMS Tonon near the mouth of the Potomac in Chesapeake Bay. Now, some people may remember HMS Tonin, Tom. Do you remember it? That's the question.
他们向切萨皮克湾航行，寻找英国舰队，因为他们认为那个叫比恩斯的家伙被关在那里。9月7日，他们在切萨皮克湾波托马克河口附近发现了“托内尔”号（HMS Tonant）。现在，有些人可能还记得“托内尔”号，汤姆。你记得吗？这是个问题。
Well, the name is, of course, the French one. And we have done a series on a particular British Admiral who's very good at capturing French. ships. We have. Now can anyone remember the name of that Admiral? Is it Admiral Nelson? It is. Superb. So, Tonor had been captured at the Nile. It had fought splendidly under Captain Charles Tyler at Trafalgar. It had
嗯，这个名字当然是法语的。我们做过一个关于一位非常擅长俘获法国船只的英国海军上将的系列节目。我们做过。现在有人记得那位海军上将的名字吗？是纳尔逊海军上将吗？是的。太棒了。“托内尔”号曾在尼罗河海战中被俘。它在查尔斯·泰勒船长的指挥下在特拉法加海战中表现出色。它曾
captured a French ship and now the Tonne is fighting the Americans. Anyway, so Key approaches the Tonnel under flag of truce and he's allowed aboard. He and this agent that he's with, they are invited for dinner by the British. They're treated very well. The British bigwigs. Ross, the Irish, Irishman, has a tremendous reputation for chivalry.
俘获了一艘法国船，现在“托内尔”号正在与美国人作战。总之，基打着休战旗接近“托内尔”号，并被允许登船。他和与他在一起的代理人被英国人邀请共进晚餐。他们受到了很好的对待。英国的大人物。罗斯，那个爱尔兰人，以骑士精神闻名。
Very chivalrous. Charming man. So when they say to Ross, can we have Dr. This bloke, Dr. Beans? Ross says, I don't know. And Key has brought letters from wounded British soldiers, British prisoners of war, saying that American doctors as a group have been very kind to them. And Ross reads these letters, and he says, oh, well, okay, fine. You can have, you know, maybe beans can go. Because he's a warm-hearted man. He's a, yeah, kindly. So it looks like they're just going to go about with this bloat beans.
非常有骑士风度。迷人的人。所以当他们对罗斯说，我们能要回比恩斯医生吗？罗斯说，我不知道。基带来了受伤的英国士兵、英国战俘的信件，说美国医生作为一个群体对他们非常好。罗斯读了这些信，他说，哦，好吧，没问题。你可以带走，你知道，也许比恩斯可以走。因为他是一个热心肠的人。他是一个，是的，和蔼可亲的人。所以看起来他们只是要带走这个叫比恩斯的家伙。
However, while they've been having dinner, the Americans have overheard the British officers talking about how they're going to attack Baltimore. And so the British say, well, since you've heard us talking about this, you're going to have to stay with us until the operation is over. And so Key and Beans are transferred to another ship, HMS Surprise, which is towing the little ship that they'd arrived on. And they all moved together up the Chesapeake towards Baltimore. And on the 11th, the Americans are allowed to go back to their own ship, which is still tethered to HMS surprise, and they're basically under military guard.
然而，当他们吃晚饭时，美国人无意中听到英国军官谈论他们将如何攻击巴尔的摩。所以英国人说，既然你们听到了我们谈论这件事，你们就得和我们待在一起，直到行动结束。所以基和比恩斯被转移到另一艘船上，即“惊喜”号（HMS Surprise），它拖着他们到达的那艘小船。他们一起向切萨皮克湾上游向巴尔的摩移动。11日，美国人被允许回到他们自己的船上，这艘船仍然系在“惊喜”号上，他们基本上处于军事监视之下。
The 12th, nothing happens. They're just hanging around, a bit bored. And then at dawn on the 13th, the British opened a bombardment of Baltimore. Or more specifically, they open the bombardment of the fort that guards the entrance to Baltimore Harbour, which is Fort McHenry, which is the Fort in the Anthem. So Key, and this medical busybody, this massive fun sponge, Dr. Peens, who's been trying to stop our brave lads looting. They're watching this from a safe distance on their ship. They're about eight miles away, and they can see that this bombardment is a really big deal. So the attack is led by HMS Erebus, which is firing Congreve rockets.
12日，什么也没发生。他们只是在附近闲逛，有点无聊。然后在13日黎明，英国人对巴尔的摩发动了轰炸。或者更具体地说，他们对守卫巴尔的摩港入口的堡垒进行了轰炸，这就是麦克亨利堡，也就是国歌中的那个堡垒。所以基，还有这个爱管闲事的医生，这个巨大的快乐杀手，比恩斯医生，他一直试图阻止我们勇敢的小伙子抢劫。他们从船上安全距离观察这一切。他们在大约八英里外，他们可以看到这次轰炸是一件大事。所以攻击由“厄瑞玻斯”号（HMS Erebus）领导，它发射了康格里夫火箭。
So if you know the American National Anthem, the rockets red glare, these are the Congreve rockets being fired by HMS Erebus. I mean, they're dangerous, aren't they? They're very dangerous. They basically, the British use them to burn down Copenhagen. Yeah. You know, anyone who remembers our Nelson era podcasts will remember that, you know, naval bombardments are not a bundle of laughs. No. So there are, just as at Copenhagen, there are also bomb vessels, specialist bomb vessels.
所以如果你知道美国国歌，“火箭红光闪烁”，这些就是“厄瑞玻斯”号发射的康格里夫火箭。我的意思是，它们很危险，不是吗？它们非常危险。它们基本上，英国人用它们烧毁了哥本哈根。是的。你知道，任何记得我们纳尔逊时代播客的人都会记得，你知道，海军轰炸可不是什么好玩的事。不。所以有，就像在哥本哈根一样，也有炸弹船，专门的炸弹船。
So in this case, they're called Terra, Volcano, Devastation, Meteor and Etna. God, you wouldn't want to be attacked by shits with the names like that. You wouldn't. Do we still have ships like that in the Royal Navy? I don't think we do. No, we don't have any ships. do we? Yeah, we don't have any ships.
所以在这个案例中，它们被称为“泰拉”号、“火山”号、“毁灭”号、“流星”号和“埃特纳”号。天哪，你可不想被名字像那样的船攻击。你不想。我们皇家海军现在还有那样的船吗？我想我们没有。不，我们没有任何船。对吧？是的，我们没有任何船。
These ships are firing shells at the fort, and these are the bombs bursting in air from the anthem. And over the next 24 hours or so, they fire a total of 700 rockets, 1,500 shells. However, although you quake at the thought of these rockets and shells, Tom, they're not very effective. Because Fort McHenry is equipped with very powerful artillery, so the British have to stay back at the very limit of their range. and they don't really do that much damage. They kill four people. They wound 24, but they don't really have any impact whatsoever
这些船正在向堡垒发射炮弹，这就是国歌中“空中炸弹爆炸”的来源。在接下来的24小时左右，他们总共发射了700枚火箭，1500枚炮弹。然而，虽然你听到这些火箭和炮弹会颤抖，汤姆，但它们并不是很有效。因为麦克亨利堡配备了非常强大的火炮，所以英国人不得不保持在他们射程的极限。他们并没有造成太大的破坏。他们杀死了四个人。他们打伤了24人，但他们并没有产生任何影响
on the fort's defences. I wonder what Nelson would have done. He would have launched an operation at land that would have involved him losing an arm, surely. Falling in love with an unsuitable American adventuress. There's a good historical novel in that. Anyway, Kee, Francis Scott Key is watching this. He can't tell that they're not having any effect.
对堡垒的防御。我想知道纳尔逊会怎么做。他肯定会发动一次陆地行动，这会让他失去一只手臂。爱上一个不合适的美国女冒险家。那里面有一部很好的历史小说。总之，基，弗朗西斯·斯科特·基正在观察这一切。他看不出它们没有产生任何效果。
He's just in awe at the general spectacle. It seemed as though Mother Earth, had opened and was vomiting shut and shell and a sheet of fire and brimstone, he says. Anyway, darkness falls. There's just this kind of vague red blur in the distance. More stuff is exploding on the walls of the fort. Basically, he all night, he's kind of watching this and he's thinking, like, has the fort fallen? You know, what's going on?
他只是对整个奇观感到敬畏。他说，似乎大地母亲已经裂开，正在呕吐炮弹和炮弹，以及火和硫磺的火海。总之，夜幕降临。远处只有一种模糊的红色模糊。更多的东西在堡垒的墙上爆炸。基本上，他整晚都在观察这一切，他在想，堡垒陷落了吗？你知道，发生了什么事？
Because he's not a military man. So he doesn't appreciate that the British Navy is operating sportingly at the limits of what it can actually do. Exactly. Dawn breaks on the 14th and the fort still stands. And as every morning, the American commander, Major George Armistead, orders his men to raise this massive national flag, which as you said at the beginning, has 15 stars and 15 stripes. Now this flag, which is now in the Smithsonian actually, this flag has a history of its own. So a year earlier, Mater Armistead had actually said, you know, the British are probably going to attack Baltimore. We need a bloody big flag. We want to have a flag so large that the British will have no difficulty seeing it from a distance.
因为他不是军人。所以他不明白英国海军正在以一种运动的方式在它实际能做的极限内运作。完全正确。14日黎明破晓，堡垒依然屹立。像每天早上一样，美国指挥官乔治·阿米斯特德少校命令他的手下升起这面巨大的国旗，正如你在开头所说，它有15颗星和15条纹。现在这面旗帜，实际上现在在史密森尼博物馆，这面旗帜本身就有自己的历史。所以一年前，阿米斯特德少校实际上说过，你知道，英国人可能会攻击巴尔的摩。我们需要一面该死的大旗。我们想要一面如此大的旗帜，以至于英国人从远处看它都不会有任何困难。
So he basically wanted this flag as a sort of emblem of defiance. And he commissioned the flag, which is absolutely massive. It's 42 feet by 30 feet. He commissioned it from a Baltimore widow called Mary Pickersgill and she took her six weeks to make it she made it with her teenage daughter and her nieces and a servant
所以他基本上想要这面旗帜作为一种反抗的象征。他委托制作了这面旗帜，它绝对巨大。它有42英尺乘30英尺。他委托巴尔的摩的一位名叫玛丽·皮克斯吉尔的寡妇制作，她花了六个星期才完成，她和她十几岁的女儿、侄女和一个仆人一起制作了它。
I don't want to do this so boring, not another star Yeah exactly And they used 300 yards of English wool bunting Which is probably my favourite kind of bunting The stars were made of cotton They sowed them on afterwards And she was paid $405.90 for it
我不想做这个，太无聊了，又是另一颗星。是的，完全正确。他们用了300码的英国羊毛旗帜布。这可能是我最喜欢的旗帜布。星星是用棉花做的。他们后来把它们缝上去。她为此获得了405.90美元的报酬。
and then Armistead gave him her another $100 for a smaller flag called a storm flag. So during the bum bum, the storm flag was flying. And then at dawn, they raise as usual, this massive national flag. Oh, I didn't know that. So actually, I'd always thought that the flag, you know, had been hit by shell and all concrete rockets and stuff, but was still flying boldly. But that's a kind of cheat. It is a cheat, it's a total com. Yeah.
然后阿米斯特德又给了她100美元，买了一面较小的旗帜，叫风暴旗。所以在大轰炸期间，风暴旗在飘扬。然后在黎明时分，他们像往常一样升起了这面巨大的国旗。哦，我不知道。所以实际上，我一直以为旗帜，你知道，被炮弹和所有康格里夫火箭之类的东西击中，但仍然勇敢地飘扬。但这是一种欺骗。这是一种欺骗，这是一个彻底的骗局。是的。
So this huge flag appears. Francis Scott Key sees the flag and he says to himself, oh, this is brilliant. The fort has held out. Now, of course, he thinks this is a great underdog triumph. What he doesn't know is there was actually never really any possibility that the fort would fall because the British were too far away. But anyway, on land the British had been advancing,
所以这面巨大的旗帜出现了。弗朗西斯·斯科特·基看到了旗帜，他对自己说，哦，这太棒了。堡垒坚持住了。现在，当然，他认为这是一个伟大的弱者胜利。他不知道的是，实际上堡垒陷落的可能性从来都不大，因为英国人离得太远了。但无论如何，在陆地上英国人一直在推进，
and that hasn't gone terribly well either. I'm sorry to say that Major General Ross, so you were complimenting earlier on. He has been shot by a sniper at the border. battle of North Point. So in this grotesque act of cowardice and cheating, he's been killed. No. Yeah, the British have fallen back.
那也没有进行得太好。我很遗憾地说，你刚才称赞的罗斯少校。他在北角战役中被狙击手击中了。所以在这个卑鄙和欺骗的怪诞行为中，他被杀了。不。是的，英国人撤退了。
They didn't write an anthem about that. No. So a couple of days later, the British say, well, this is too tough enough to crack. We'll call off the operation. Anyway, while that's been going on, Key, has been sitting on this ship, still kind of basically under guard, twiddling his thumbs. So what's the guy to do when you're twiddling your thumbs? Maybe write an anthem?
他们没有为此写国歌。不。所以几天后，英国人说，好吧，这块骨头太硬了，啃不动。我们取消行动吧。总之，当这一切发生时，基一直坐在那艘船上，仍然基本上处于监视之下，转动着他的拇指。那么当你转动拇指时，一个人该做什么呢？也许写一首国歌？
Well, not an anthem. he decides to write a poem. Oh, right. So, you will often read on the internet that he writes it on the back of an envelope that he'd found in his pocket. And it turns out that this is an untruth. He didn't write it on an envelope. And there's a historian who has dug deep into this story called Mark Clegg. And he says, no, envelopes weren't used in 1814.
嗯，不是国歌。他决定写一首诗。哦，对。所以，你经常会在互联网上读到他是在他口袋里发现的一个信封背面写的。结果发现这是一个谎言。他不是在信封上写的。有一位深入挖掘这个故事的历史学家叫马克·克莱格。他说，不，1814年不使用信封。
or rather they were only used on very special occasions by the rich. So Key would have, if he was going to write a letter, he would have folded it over and not used an envelope so he couldn't have had an envelope. So with sealing wax, I guess, and a stamp. And Key would undoubtedly have taken a lot of blank paper with him for the negotiations for this doctor's release and to write a letter to President Madison about how he was getting on. this would have been good paper and not scrap paper.
或者更确切地说，它们只在富人的非常特殊的场合使用。所以基，如果他要写一封信，他会把它折起来，而不是使用信封，所以他不可能有信封。所以用火漆，我想，还有一个邮票。基无疑会随身携带大量空白纸，用于这次医生释放的谈判，并写信给麦迪逊总统关于他的进展。这会是好纸，而不是废纸。
So, on some of this high-quality note paper, Key writes his poem. And finally that evening, he, it's what are we there, the 16th or something, he and the others are allowed to go back to Baltimore. And he's got a room at the Indian Queen Hotel, and he finishes his poem there. And the handwritten draft of the poem, you can see at the Maryland Historical Society.
所以，在这些高质量的便签纸上，基写了他的诗。最后那天晚上，他，我们到了哪里，16号还是什么的，他和其他人被允许回到巴尔的摩。他在印度女王酒店有一个房间，他在那里完成了他的诗。这首诗的手稿，你可以在马里兰历史协会看到。
And he can actually see how he's written three verses, and then he's kind of running out of space, and he has to cram the fourth verse into the last kind of inch of paper. It's like a sort of child's letter. Yeah, we've all been there. Yeah, exactly. Now, I mean, he was wasting his time
而且你实际上可以看到他是如何写了三节，然后他有点空间不够了，他不得不把第四节塞进纸的最后几英寸。这就像一种孩子的信。是的，我们都经历过。是的，完全正确。现在，我的意思是，他在浪费时间
because no one sings the fourth verse. No one cares about the fourth verse. It's the first verse that everyone sings, right? So it's the story, O'Say, can you see by the dawn's early light what so proudly we hailed at the twilight's last gleaming. Then there's all his stuff about the bombs and the rockets. And then the final lines,
因为没有人唱第四节。没有人关心第四节。每个人唱的都是第一节，对吧？所以这是故事，“哦，说，你能看见吗，在黎明的第一道曙光中，我们如此自豪地欢呼，在黄昏的最后一道微光中。”然后是他关于炸弹和火箭的所有东西。然后是最后几行，
O'Say, does that star-spangled banner yet wave? over the land of the free and the home of the brave. It's very kind of 1800s, 1810s, slightly gushing, romantic kind of rhetoric. And not true, to reiterate, he shows this to his brother-in-law, who commands a local militia unit. And his brother-in-law takes it to a printer,
“哦，说，那面星条旗还在飘扬吗？在自由之地和勇敢者的家园之上。”这非常像1800年代、1810年代，稍微有点夸张、浪漫的修辞。而且不真实，重申一下，他把这个展示给他的姐夫看，他指挥着一个当地的民兵单位。他的姐夫把它带给了一个印刷商，
they run off a thousand copies, and then they hand them out to the garrison of Fort Henry. And then the really key thing, his brother-in-law gives it to the Baltimore Patriot newspaper, which prints it under the... title, Defence of Fort McHenry, and then other papers copy it. So as we approach the break, a couple of things about this poem. I've called it a poem, and in fact, you said it was a song and I said, I know it's a poem, but I was being a little bit unfair there, because actually
他们印了一千份，然后把它们分发给亨利堡的驻军。然后真正关键的事情是，他的姐夫把它给了《巴尔的摩爱国者》报纸，该报以……标题《保卫麦克亨利堡》印刷了它，然后其他报纸复制了它。所以当我们接近休息时，关于这首诗的几件事。我称它为诗，事实上，你说它是一首歌，我说，我知道它是一首诗，但我当时有点不公平，因为实际上
it's somewhere in between the two. It's a thing called a broadside ballad. And basically, what a broadside ballad was, you would write lyrics or write a poem to fit a very familiar tune. You would say this tune is a banger. I'm going to write new words for this tune. I'm going to publish them in a newspaper. And the reason you would use an old tune is that even if you wanted to write a new tune, it's more expensive to print music than it is to print words. And the reason is because you have to do the musical notation. It has to be engraved by hand. So you'd be better to reuse an old tune. And also, copyright law is not all it could be. Because there is no. copyright law, you Tom might write lyrics to the tune of Taxman by the Beatles.
它介于两者之间。它是一种叫做“宽边民谣”的东西。基本上，什么是宽边民谣，你会写歌词或写一首诗来配合一个非常熟悉的曲调。你会说这个曲调很棒。我要为这个曲调写新词。我要在报纸上发表它们。你使用旧曲调的原因是，即使你想写一个新曲调，印刷音乐比印刷文字更贵。原因是，因为你必须做乐谱。它必须手工雕刻。所以你最好重用一个旧曲调。而且，版权法也不是它可能的样子。因为没有。版权法，你汤姆可以写歌词配合披头士乐队的《税务员》的曲调。
Yes. And you would publish them in the Daily Telegraph and you would put a little note saying, you know, tune Taxman by the Beatles. And there'd be nothing the Beatles could do about it. No. Because there'd be no copyright law. Correct. If your lyrics were a hit, you would hope that other newspapers, The Daily Express, the Daily Mail. the Daily Mail, the Guardian.
是的。你会把它们发表在《每日电讯报》上，你会写一个小注说，你知道，曲调是披头士乐队的《税务员》。披头士乐队对此无能为力。不。因为没有版权法。正确。如果你的歌词很受欢迎，你会希望其他报纸，《每日快报》、《每日邮报》。《每日邮报》，《卫报》。
The Guardian probably not, I think. It depends what I've written. These other newspapers might reprint your lyrics and they'd kind of go viral and you'd be the talk of the town. Other people would shake your hand as they saw you go by.
《卫报》可能不会，我想。这取决于我写了什么。这些其他报纸可能会重印你的歌词，它们会有点病毒式传播，你会成为全城的话题。当你走过时，其他人会和你握手。
And actually, Francis Scott Key has formed for doing this. So in 1805 he'd written his first patriotic broadside ballad when the warrior returns, which was celebrating US naval victories against the Barbary Corsairs in Tripoli.
事实上，弗朗西斯·斯科特·基有做这件事的习惯。所以在1805年，他写了他的第一首爱国宽边民谣《当战士归来时》，这是为了庆祝美国海军在的黎波里对巴巴里海盗的胜利。
Oh, yeah. The American Navy was always fighting them, weren't they? Yes, exactly. They're some of their first wars. Bizarly against North African, nominally Ottoman kind of, I don't know, the Emirates or something on the coast of North Africa.
哦，是的。美国海军一直在和他们作战，不是吗？是的，完全正确。他们最早的一些战争。奇怪的是针对北非，名义上是奥斯曼帝国的那种，我不知道，酋长国或北非海岸上的什么东西。
They're always capturing people and take them into slavery. Yes, exactly. This is the third verse of when the warrior returns. And if you know, the Starzbank or Bani, you will spot the similarities. In the conflict resistless, it's tall they endured,
他们一直在俘虏人并把他们变成奴隶。是的，完全正确。这是《当战士归来时》的第三节。如果你知道《星条旗》，你会发现相似之处。“在冲突中不可抗拒，它高高挺立，他们忍受着，
to their foes fled to, made from the war's desolation, and pale beamed the crescent, its splendor obscured by the light of the star-spangled flag of our nation, where each radiant star gleamed a meteor of war, and the turbaned heads bowed to its terrible glare, now mixed with the olive, the laurel shall wave, and form a bright wreath for the brows of the brave. So the rhythm might sound familiar, because this is written for the same tune as the Star-Spangled banner. And that's a little bit of the Star Spangor Banner. And that tune, this will shock our American listeners. This will appall them and make them question existence itself. It's a English tune. The tune is
向他们的敌人逃跑，从战争的荒凉中制造，苍白的月牙光芒，它的辉煌被我们国家星条旗的光芒所掩盖，每一颗灿烂的星星闪烁着战争的流星，缠着头巾的头向它可怕的眩光低头，现在与橄榄混合，月桂树将飘扬，为勇敢者的额头形成一个明亮的花环。”所以节奏听起来可能很熟悉，因为这是为与《星条旗》相同的曲调而写的。这就是《星条旗》的一点点。而那个曲调，这会让我们的美国听众感到震惊。这会让他们感到震惊，让他们质疑存在本身。这是一个英国曲调。曲调是
called the Anacriotic Song. And it was written in 1775 by a man called John Stafford Smith. Now, you'll sometimes read online that it was a bawdy drinking song of the kind that No doubt the author's cricket team sing to jead themselves up, a tea between innings. Do you not sing bawdy drinking songs? No, we would sing Anacrianatic songs. Would you? Surely you would. Because we are great fans of the ancient Greek poet, Anacrian.
叫做《阿那克里翁之歌》。它由一个叫约翰·斯塔福德·史密斯的人在1775年创作。现在，你有时会在网上读到它是一首淫秽的饮酒歌，那种毫无疑问作者的板球队在局间休息时唱来振奋精神的歌。你们不唱淫秽的饮酒歌吗？不，我们会唱阿那克里翁之歌。你们会吗？你们肯定会。因为我们是古希腊诗人阿那克里翁的忠实粉丝。
Of course. Whose lyric poetry was designed to be sung. Well. And so there is a kind of classical model here. Yes. There's a faint hint of Emma Hamilton's attitudes about it. Actitudes. Trying to bring to life a kind of ancient Greek art form.
当然。他的抒情诗旨在被演唱。嗯。所以这里有一种古典模型。是的。有一点艾玛·汉密尔顿态度的暗示。姿态。试图让一种古希腊艺术形式复活。
I think that's kind of basically what's going on. I should never have opened the door to Emma Hamilton, reappearing in the Spockast. Anyway, she has. So basically, there was a club in London, founded in 1766, called the Anacriotic Club. And this was for men who were interested in music. And basically, when they would go to the club,
我想这基本上就是正在发生的事情。我不应该打开艾玛·汉密尔顿重新出现在播客中的门。总之，她出现了。所以基本上，伦敦有一个俱乐部，成立于1766年，叫做阿那克里翁俱乐部。这是为对音乐感兴趣的男士准备的。基本上，当他们去俱乐部时，
there would be a professional singer often who was hired to sing this song. and would be accompanied on the harpsichord. So it's not really a bawdy vibe. No, no. Yeah, the men would all listen to this song and then they would sing some songs at their own. Now, Key knows about this song because versions of it are already popular in the United States.
通常会有一位被雇来唱这首歌的专业歌手。并会由大键琴伴奏。所以这并不是真正的淫秽氛围。不，不。是的，男人们都会听这首歌，然后他们会唱一些他们自己的歌。现在，基知道这首歌，因为它的版本在美国已经很流行了。
So there's actually a historian at the University of Newcastle in our own country, Dr. Oscar Jensen, who has looked into this. And it had been taken up by abolitionists. So a version of it called Millions be free, had been produced by a Liverpool abolitionist to celebrate the fall of the Bastille. Thomas Payne sang it. Mary Wollstonecraft wrote about it, and it was taken by abolitionists to America in the mid-1790s. It was printed in New York and Baltimore, interestingly, under the title
所以实际上在我们国家纽卡斯尔大学有一位历史学家，奥斯卡·詹森博士，他研究过这个问题。它已经被废奴主义者采用了。所以一个叫《让数百万人自由》的版本，是由一位利物浦废奴主义者制作的，为了庆祝巴士底狱的陷落。托马斯·潘唱了它。玛丽·沃斯通克拉夫特写了关于它的文章，它被废奴主义者在18世纪90年代中期带到了美国。它在纽约和巴尔的摩印刷，有趣的是，标题是
Freedom Triumphant. It spread. People liked the tune. American politicians used it. So there was a song supporting John Adams in the presidential election of 1796 that used it. And in fact, by 1820, there are 80 different songs at least using the anacriotic melody. So they all follow the same pattern. Each verse is eight lines long. There is a rhyme at the end of each line and there is also an extra rhyme in the middle of the fifth line. So every verse has actually nine rhymes. So Francis Scott Key, undoubtedly writes his star spangled banner to fit this pattern. And it's precisely because it's so familiar, because people really know about it, that it's a hit. People like songs they already know. So it's printed by more newspapers. By October of 1814, it's been printed
凯旋的自由。它传播开来。人们喜欢这个曲调。美国政客们也用了它。因此，在1796年的总统大选中，有一首支持约翰·亚当斯的歌曲就用了这个曲调。事实上，到1820年，至少有80首不同的歌曲使用了这首阿纳克里翁式的旋律。它们都遵循同样的模式。每节诗有八行。每一行的末尾都有押韵，第五行的中间还有一个额外的押韵。所以每一节实际上有九个韵脚。因此，弗朗西斯·斯科特·基无疑是为了适应这种模式而写下了他的《星条旗》。正是因为它如此耳熟能详，因为人们真的了解它，所以它才大受欢迎。人们喜欢他们已经熟悉的歌曲。因此，它被更多的报纸印刷。到1814年10月，它已经被印刷
in newspapers from New England to Georgia. And that autumn of 1814, a shop in Baltimore, the car music store, starts selling copies of the lyrics. And the owner, Thomas Carr is the person who gives it its title, the title we know today, The Star Spangled Banner. And is he publishing that with the music or just the lyrics? And people are, you know, he assumes that people will recognize the tune that goes with it. That's an excellent question. I would guess you could buy the music, but it would be more expensive because it's more expensive to produce. So that's how the thing is created. But of course, that's only half the story because there's absolutely no talk at this point that it could be the national anthem. And it won't become the
在从新英格兰到佐治亚州的报纸上。1814年那个秋天，巴尔的摩的一家商店，卡尔音乐商店，开始出售歌词的副本。店主托马斯·卡尔就是给它起名的人，也就是我们今天所知的名字——《星条旗》。他是连同音乐一起出版，还是只出版歌词？人们，你知道，他假设人们会认出与之相配的曲调。这是一个很好的问题。我猜你可以买到乐谱，但会更贵，因为制作成本更高。这就是这首歌的创作过程。但当然，这只是故事的一半，因为此时完全没有讨论它可能成为国歌。而且它也不会在
National Anthem for more than a century. And actually, right from the beginning, there is a shadow over this song. And this is the allegation that the song is a glorification of slavery. So, I mean, I have to say that this came as a bombshell to me, may come as a bombshell to many patriotic American listeners. So please join us after the break where Dominic will be justifying this claim. This episode is brought to you by The Times and the Sunday Times. Tom has another summer of top international football returns. It's truly incredible, isn't it, to think about how much the world has changed between the various tournaments. Looking back to when England hosted back in 1966, everyone in the crowd supporting England were waving Union jacks.
国歌，直到一个多世纪以后。事实上，从一开始，这首歌就笼罩着阴影。这就是关于这首歌是美化奴隶制的指控。所以，我的意思是，我必须说这对我是个重磅炸弹，对许多爱国的美籍听众来说也可能是一个重磅炸弹。所以请在休息后加入我们，届时多米尼克将为这一说法辩护。本集由《泰晤士报》和《星期日泰晤士报》赞助播出。汤姆又迎来了一个顶级国际足球回归的夏天。回想一下世界在各届锦标赛之间发生了多大的变化，真是令人难以置信，不是吗？回望1966年英格兰主办比赛时，人群中支持英格兰的每个人都挥舞着联合杰克旗。
So what fascinating trends does that illustrate? And I suppose the last time the United States hosted the tournament was in 1994. And the mood in America in the early 1990s, you know, the Cold War was over. Clinton was in the White House. I was there for that. I was in Boston. Really? I mean, that's an aspect of the story that's very rarely reported on your presence.
那么这说明了什么迷人的趋势呢？我想美国上一次主办锦标赛是在1994年。20世纪90年代初美国的氛围，你知道，冷战结束了。克林顿在白宫。我当时就在那里。我在波士顿。真的吗？我的意思是，这是故事中很少被报道的一个方面，关于你的存在。
I know. So you know what this reminds me of, Tom? It reminds me that the future is always uncertain. You never know what's coming. But the facts need not be uncertain. And when the world feels like it's moving too fast, the times and the Sunday Daytimes empower you to make smarter, more confident decisions. Click or tap the banner now to learn more or visit the times.com.
我知道。所以你知道这让我想起了什么吗，汤姆？它提醒我，未来总是充满不确定性。你永远不知道会发生什么。但事实不必是不确定的。当世界感觉发展太快时，《泰晤士报》和《星期日泰晤士报》让你能够做出更明智、更自信的决定。现在点击或轻按横幅了解更多信息，或访问thetimes.com。
Hello everyone and welcome back to the rest is history and we, or more properly Dominic, left you with the suggestion that the star-spangled banner might be, as well as the glorification of America and Liberty, the glorification of America and Liberty, the glorification of the of slavery as well, and I can only imagine we'll have had thousands of Americans canceling their subscriptions, but you were not the first to come up with this allegation, right? Not at all. The National Association for the Advancement of Coloured People. So in November 2017, this venerable civil rights group actually petitioned Congress to scrap
大家好，欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》，我们，或者更准确地说是多米尼克，留给你们一个暗示，即《星条旗》可能不仅是对美国和自由的颂扬，也是对美国和自由的颂扬，同时也是对奴隶制的颂扬，我只能想象会有成千上万的美国人取消订阅，但你并不是第一个提出这种指控的人，对吧？一点也不。全国有色人种协进会。所以，在2017年11月，这个受人尊敬的民权组织实际上向国会请愿，要求废除
the Star-Spangled banner as the National Anthem. The president of the California NAACP, Alice Huffman, said, and I quote, it's racist, it doesn't represent our community, it is anti-black. So what's going on here? Because to the degree that I am familiar with the lyrics, I don't see anything about slavery in it. I mean, there's one mention of slaves, isn't there? But that's about it.
《星条旗》作为国歌。加州全国有色人种协进会主席爱丽丝·霍夫曼说，我引用一下，“它是种族主义的，它不代表我们的社区，它是反黑人的。”那么这里发生了什么？因为就我所熟悉的歌词而言，我没有在里面看到任何关于奴隶制的内容。我的意思是，提到了一次奴隶，不是吗？但仅此而已。
Well, okay. So let's get into this because it's actually a fascinating subject and it opens up a lot more of the history of the 1810s. So people only really sing the first verse. In the third verse, in the second half, now remember this is something that nobody ever sings, Francis Scott Key is exulting in the aftermath of the British withdrawal. No refuge could save the hireling and slave from the terror of flight or the gloom of the grave. And the star-spangled banner in triumph doth wave are the land of the free and the home of the brave.
好吧，好的。那么让我们深入探讨一下，因为这实际上是一个迷人的主题，它开启了1810年代更多的历史。所以人们真的只唱第一节。在第三节的后半部分，现在记住这是没人会唱的部分，弗朗西斯·斯科特·基在英国撤军后的余波中欢呼雀跃。“没有避难所能拯救雇佣兵和奴隶，免于逃亡的恐惧或坟墓的阴霾。而星条旗在胜利中飘扬，在自由之地和勇敢者的家园。”
And the issue focuses on those words, the hireling and slave. Now, lots of commentators say, without really thinking about it, oh, well, this must be African-American slaves who were trying to escape from their owners and flee to the British. See, I would not have said that. I would have said that these are insults applied to soldiers fighting under the British crown. Right. That dates from the years of the American Revolution. Yes. And the slaves are the British soldiers who are subjects to a king.
问题集中在“雇佣兵和奴隶”这些词上。现在，许多评论员不假思索地说，哦，好吧，这一定是那些试图逃离主人并逃往英国人的非裔美国奴隶。看，我不会那样说。我会说这些是适用于在英国王室下作战的士兵的侮辱。对。这可以追溯到美国革命时期。是的。而奴隶是那些服从于国王的英国士兵。
and the hirelings are the Hessian mercenaries who were brought in. And so they're applying that rhetoric now in a new war. That's what I would say. That's what I had assumed. My initial reaction was to completely agree with you. I thought that too. Francis Scott Key's biographer, Mark Clegg, distinguished historian in the United States, he absolutely agrees with you.
而雇佣兵是被带进来的黑森雇佣兵。所以他们现在在新的战争中应用这种修辞。这就是我会说的。这就是我所假设的。我最初的反应是完全同意你。我也那么想。弗朗西斯·斯科特·基的传记作者，美国杰出的历史学家马克·克莱格，他完全同意你的观点。
He says, listen, Americans in the late 18th and early 19th century used the words hireling and slave to refer to British subjects of King George III. They use them as exactly as you say to refer to hired mercenaries and their local collaborators. And he says, actually, when you look at American propaganda, the word slavery is often a code word for submission to the British king. Illoyalism. Exactly. And this is in the context of Canada as well. Yes, exactly. Which hasn't been conquered. So yeah, that's what I'd have thought. And we in Britain are very used to this issue because, of course, there is the issue of rule Britannia. So in rule Britannia, the words Britons never, never shall be slaves or whatever it is,
他说，听着，18世纪末和19世纪初的美国人使用“雇佣兵”和“奴隶”这些词来指代乔治三世国王的英国臣民。他们正如你所说，用它们来指代受雇的雇佣兵和他们的当地合作者。他说，实际上，当你审视美国宣传时，“奴隶制”这个词通常是屈服于英国国王的代号。保皇主义。完全正确。这在加拿大的背景下也是如此。是的，完全正确。它还没有被征服。所以是的，这就是我会想到的。我们英国人非常习惯这个问题，因为当然，有《统治吧，不列颠尼亚》的问题。所以在《统治吧，不列颠尼亚》中，歌词“不列颠人永远，永远不会成为奴隶”或者类似的话，
you know, there was some talk in 2020 or so, oh, Royal Britannia should be cancelled, it's terrible, it's a grower, you know, it's very tasteless about slavery. But actually the slavery being talked about in rural Britannia, it's about the Vikings, isn't it? Because it's about King Alfred. It's about King Alfred, but obviously it's a sort of, it's using submission to the Vikings as a metaphor for submission to Catholic Spain, France, etc. Yeah, but can I also ask, it derives from the kind of poem derives from an Akron who is an ancient
你知道，2020年左右有一些讨论，哦，《统治吧，不列颠尼亚》应该被取消，这太糟糕了，它是一个种植者，你知道，它对奴隶制非常没品味。但实际上《统治吧，不列颠尼亚》中谈论的奴隶制，是关于维京人的，不是吗？因为它是关于阿尔弗雷德大王的。它是关于阿尔弗雷德大王的，但显然它是一种，它使用对维京人的屈服作为对天主教西班牙、法国等屈服的隐喻。是的，但我也可以问一下，它源于某种诗歌，源于阿纳克里翁，他是一位古希腊人，古希腊的自由理想显然非常流行。罗马的自由理想，我的意思是，它是这一时期美国文化阶层语言的一部分。而雅典人或罗马人的自由的对立面，你知道，比如雅典人，是那些在马拉松战役中为波斯国王而战的人的奴隶制。是的，当然。我同意所有这些。我完全同意。然而，当你更仔细地审视这一点时，这个故事还有另一面。有理由认为基是在谈论非裔美国奴隶。一个是关于背景，另一个是关于基本人。
Greek and the ancient Greek ideals of liberty is obviously very current. The Roman ideals of liberty, I mean, it's part of the kind of the language of the American culture class in this period. And the counterpoint to the liberty of the Athenians or the Romans, you know, say the Athenians, it's the slavery of those who were fighting for the Persian king at Marathon. Yeah, of course. I agree with all that. I totally agree. However, when you look more closely into this, there is another side of this story. There are reasons to think that Key was talking about African-American slaves. And one is to do with the context, and the other to do is to do
所以如果我们从背景开始，在上半部分，我们描述了乔治·科伯恩的目标是如何突袭和摧毁大西洋沿岸的城镇和港口。为了引导他的突袭部队，他需要当地的情报。从他1813年到达的那一刻起，他和英国其他船长主要依赖一个群体，那就是逃跑的奴隶。对，这又是可以追溯到美国独立战争的事情，不是吗？因为这是英国的一项策略，如果南方奴隶加入英国，就给予他们自由。完全正确。起初，英国船只和英国部队会吸引个别逃跑的奴隶。但随着时间的推移，
with Key himself. So if we start with the context, in the first half, we described how George Coburn's objective was to raid and destroy the towns and harbors on the Atlantic Sea board. To guide his raiding parties, he needed local intelligence. And from the moment he arrived in 1813, he and the other British captains relied on one group above all, which was escaped slaves. Right. And that again is something that goes back to the American War of Independence, isn't it? Because this was a British strategy to offer slaves in the south their freedom if they would join the British. Exactly. So at first, British ships and British parties would attract individual runaway slaves. But over time,
他们开始吸引更大的群体和家庭群体等等。当科伯恩在1814年回来时，他一直在百慕大过冬，但他回来后，他加倍努力。他对他的船长们说，我希望你们不遗余力地吸引当地的奴隶人口，我引用一下，“你们所做的登陆更多是为了保护黑人人口的逃亡，而不是为了任何其他利益。要达到的伟大目标是黑人人口的真诚支持。只要他们装备精良，并有2万名英国军队的支持，麦迪逊先生就会被从他的宝座上赶下来。”
they start to attract larger groups and family groups and so on. And when Coburn came back in 1814, he'd been wintering in Bermuda, but then he comes back, he doubled down on this. And he said to his captains, I want you to go out of your way to appeal to the local slave population. And I quote, Let the landings you make be more for the protection of the desertion of the black population than with a view to any other advantage. The great point to be attained is the cordial support of the black population. With them properly armed and backed with 20,000 British troops, Mr. Madison will be hurled from his throne.
作为其中的一部分，他做出了一个非常具体的承诺。所有逃跑的奴隶都将受到英国人的欢迎，在任何情况下都不会被交还。当英国人在美国独立战争中尝试这项政策时，它显然受到了极大的损害，因为英国人自己正在保卫加勒比地区的种植园，那里有奴隶。奴隶制并非非法。
And as part of this, he makes a very specific promise. All runaway slaves will be welcomed by the British, and under no circumstances will they be handed back. When the British tried this policy in the American War of Independence, it was obviously massively compromised because the British themselves were defending the plantations in the Caribbean on which there were slaves. Slavery was not illegal.
到这一点，你有一位英国外交大臣即将前往维也纳会议，并推动废除奴隶贸易。是的。与其他大国一起。你认为这会传到黑人美国人那里吗？很难说，
By this point, you have a British foreign secretary who is about to go to the Congress of Vienna and press for the abolition of the slave trade. Yeah. With the other great powers. Is that something you think that would have filtered through to black Americans? Very hard to say,
因为你真的不会，你找不到多少文本证据。是的，你怎么能找到它？但也许它只是某种，你知道，它在小道消息中。我的意思是，我会想象，英国政府已经转向废奴主义者，这将是一个大新闻。毫无疑问，他所提供的消息确实，你知道，过滤掉了。是的，你可以很好地想象人们说，好吧，英国人已经在谈论废除它了。而他实际上所做的让白人美国舆论感到非常震惊的事情是，他说，所有男性逃跑的奴隶都将被武装起来。
because you wouldn't really have, you wouldn't find much textual evidence. Yeah, how would you find it? But maybe it's just kind of, you know, it's on the grapevine. I mean, it would be big news, I would imagine, that the British government has turned abolitionist. There was absolutely no doubt that the news of what he is offering does, you know, filter through. And yes, you could well imagine people saying, well, the British have already talking about scrapping it. And what actually he does that really horrifies white American opinion, he says, all male runaway slaves will be armed.
他们将被给予红色制服，并被编入一个名为“殖民海军陆战队”的特殊部队。是的，因为这就是困扰最初三K党的噩梦，不是吗？在我们内战后做的那个系列中，没有什么比武装黑人反抗他们或被鼓励反抗他们更让南方白人奴隶主感到恐惧的了。无论如何，这支殖民海军陆战队确实参与了行动。他们在5月底投入战斗，他们表现得非常好。他们的英国军官说，
they will be given red uniforms and they will be put in a special unit called the Corps of Colonial Marines. Yeah, because this is the nightmare that haunted the original Ku Klux Klan, isn't it? In that series that we did after the Civil War, nothing ever frightens white, southern slave holders more
对殖民海军陆战队的表现非常满意，每个人都表现出与前主人交战的极大渴望。科伯恩本人写道，他们在美国平民中引发了最普遍和不加掩饰的恐慌。甚至有前奴隶参与了华盛顿的焚烧，你可能会猜到，这对他们来说一定是甜蜜的复仇。无论如何，相比之下，美国人认为这绝对是可怕的。他们认为这是一种暴行。
than the prospect of armed black men rising up against them or being emboldened against them. Anyway, this Corps of Colonial Marines did see action. They went into battle in Virginia and the end of May and they did really well. Their British officers said,
他们认为这是作弊。但他们认为这不仅仅是作弊。他们认为武装他们的前奴隶来对抗他们是对上帝和自然法则的侮辱。一位高级军官在1814年8月写道，我们的黑人正从四面八方涌向敌人，他们将他们转化为复仇心强且贪婪的军队，对每一条小路都有最细致的了解。
was highly pleased by the conduct of the colonial marines, every individual of which evinced the greatest eagerness to come to action with their former masters. And Coburn himself wrote, They trigger the most general and undisguised alarm among American civilians. There were even former slaves involved in the Bernie of Washington, which must have been sweet revenge for them, you would guess. Anyway, the Americans, by contrast, think this is absolutely terrible. They think it's an outrage.
他们离开我们，作为我们哨所和实力的间谍，他们回来作为向导、士兵和纵火犯。一位来自史密森尼学会美国国家历史博物馆的人，克里斯托弗·威尔逊写道。讽刺的是，就在基写下关于“自由之地”的诗歌时，非裔美国奴隶正试图逃离“自由之地”，到达巴尔的摩港的那些英国船只，
They think it's cheating. But they think it's more than cheating. They think it's an affront to the laws of God and of nature to arm their former slaves against them. One senior officer writes in August 1814, Our Negroes are flocking to the enemy from all quarters, which they convert into troops of vindictive and rapacious, with the most minute knowledge of every by-path.
这些船只是诗歌的对手。正如克里斯托弗·威尔逊，这位来自博物馆的人所引用的，他们知道在联合杰克旗下的自由和解放的可能性远比在星条旗下的可能性大得多。他听起来是一位出色的策展人。我称赞他的客观性。
They leave us as spies upon our posts and our strength, and they returned upon us as guides and soldiers and incendiaries. a guy actually from the National Museum of American History, the Smithsonian writes Christopher Wilson. The irony is the very point when Key is writing his poem about the land of the free, black African-American slaves are trying to escape the land of the free and to reach those British ships in Baltimore Harbor
这简直是我们在这个播客上做过的最好的故事。无论如何。战争在1815年结束，基本上是平局，科伯恩信守诺言。他现在有大约6000名逃跑的奴隶，而条约要求归还
that are the antagonists of the poem. And as to quote Christopher Wilson, this guy from the museum, they knew that they were far more likely to find freedom and liberty under the Union Jack than they were under the Star-Spangled banner. He sounds an excellent curator. I commend him for his objectivity.
所有美国财产。所以美国人期望把他们要回来。而科伯恩没有。把他们还回去。因为一切都变了，因为英国政府现在致力于废奴主义。对。好吧，至少是废除奴隶贸易，我们这么说吧。完全正确。所以这些人中的大多数最终去了加拿大。但许多殖民海军陆战队成员，也就是那些参与过行动的人，去了特立尼达。顺便说一句，这是一个不可思议的故事。他们在老军士的指挥下被分配了特殊的村庄。他们在那里定居，
This is literally the best story we've ever done on this podcast. Anyway. The war ends in 1815, basically in a draw, and Coburn is true to his word. He now has about 6,000 escaped slaves and the treaty called for the return
他们被称为“美国人”。哇。他们今天仍然在那里，他们仍然被称为“美国人”。天哪，这太神奇了。这是一个不可思议的故事。无论如何，回到弗朗西斯·斯科特·基的国歌歌词，“没有避难所能拯救雇佣兵和奴隶，免于逃亡的恐惧或坟墓的阴霾。”
of all United States property. So the Americans expected to get them back. And Coburn did not. give them back. Because everything has changed, because the British government is now committed to abolitionism. Right. Well, at least the abolition of the slave trade, let's say. Exactly. So most of these people actually ended up in Canada. But a lot of the colonial marines, so the people who had seen action, went to Trinidad. This is an incredible story, by the way. They were given special villages under the command of their old sergeants. They settled there,
我认为他完全有可能是在谈论这些人，他们的逃亡一直是一个大故事。他基本上是在说，我们会追上你们，或者你们会死。我的意思是，我的意思是，它双向起作用，不是吗？
and they were called Americans. Wow. And they are still there today and they're still called Americans. Goodness, that's amazing. It's an incredible story. Anyway, to go back to the words of Francis Scott Key's anthem, no refuge could save the hireling and slave from the terror of flight or the gloom of the grave.
当然。我的意思是，那可能就是……双重含义。是的。是的。然而，有一个方面，我说过有理由认为它更复杂，另一个是基本人。
I think it is perfectly possible he is talking about these people whose flight has been such a big story. He is saying, basically, we will catch up with you or you will die. I mean, I mean, it works both ways, though, doesn't it?
现在，自从我们开始这个播客以来，《历史的其余部分》一直没有取消任何人或把自己设定为绞刑法官。然而，我认为作为一个局外人，你可以看出为什么黑人美国人可能会觉得很难。去庆祝弗朗西斯·斯科特·基作为一个个体。他对奴隶制的态度充其量是非常模糊的。他自己拥有奴隶。他在1800年买了第一个奴隶。到1820年他拥有六个。当他在1843年去世时，他有八个。他有时被描述为一名律师，奴隶主，寻求
Of course. I mean, that's kind of maybe the... Double meaning. Yeah. Yeah. However, there's one of the aspects, I said, there were two reasons to think it was more complicated, and the other one is key himself.
归还他们的财产。另一方面，他确实释放了一些他的奴隶。他代表寻求自由的奴隶。当他的一个朋友在遗嘱中解放了他的奴隶时，弗朗西斯·斯科特·基是执行人之一，他努力为他们争取自由。他在写这首诗之前做过这件事吗？我想是在之后。
Now, the rest is history ever since we started the podcast. We've never been into canceling people or setting ourselves up as hanging judges. However, I think as an outsider, you can see why black Americans might find it difficult. to celebrate Francis Scott Key as an individual. He has at best a very ambiguous attitude to slavery. He owns slaves himself. He bought his first slave in 1800. He owned six by 1820. When he died in 1843, he had eight. He's sometimes represented as a lawyer, slave owners, seeking the
也许他的态度演变了。好吧，我认为他的态度很复杂。他是“美国殖民协会”的创始成员和非常热心的筹款人。美国殖民协会的目标是将获得自由的黑人男女送往非洲。
return of their property. On the other hand, he did free some of his slaves. He represented slaves, who sought their freedom. And when a friend of his liberated his slaves in his will, Francis Scott Keeb was one of the executors and he worked to get them their freedom. And was he doing this before he wrote this poem? After, I think.
这就是实际上在1847年利比里亚建立中达到顶峰的项目。现在，你可能会看这个并说，嗯，这是一件非常好的事情。实际上，支持这个协会的大多数人都是奴隶主。它在马里兰州特别受欢迎。它在种植园精英中特别受欢迎。它是由一种焦虑产生的，即白人和黑人美国人永远无法生活在一起。是的，完全正确。
Maybe his attitudes evolved. Well, I think his attitudes are complicated. He is a founder member and a very keen fundraise of something called the American Colonization Society. And the goal of the American Colonization Society is to send black men and women who have been freed to Africa.
所以这很复杂，因为一方面，这些人无疑会自己说，我们是受基督教慈善的激励。我们想为这些人找到居住的地方。我们想为他们找到一个家。另一方面，筹款的人，为这个协会积极活动的人，往往是明确的种族主义者。他们说，我们是一个白人国家。
And this is the project that actually culminates in the foundation of Liberia in 1847. Now, you may look at this and say, well, that's a very nice thing to do. Actually, most of the people who backed this society were slaveholders. It was particularly popular in Maryland. It was particularly popular with the planter elite. It's kind of generated by an anxiety that white and black Americans can never live together. Yes, exactly so.
我们不希望自由的黑人男女作为公民在我们中间。摆脱他们，把他们送到非洲。事实上，许多废奴主义者和许多黑人自己都讨厌这个殖民协会，因为他们认为它，我的意思是，他们认为它毫无疑问是种族主义的。至于废奴主义，
So it's complicated because on the one hand, these people would undoubtedly have said themselves, we're motivated by Christian charity. We want to find somewhere for these people to live. We want to find them at home. On the other hand, the people who fundraise, the people who are activists for this society are often explicitly racist. They say, we're a white country.
基根本不是废奴主义的粉丝。所以你提到了纳尔逊。我们谈到了纳尔逊和奴隶制。纳尔逊不是废奴主义的粉丝，但我认为这不是他非常关心的事情。他不是它的粉丝，因为他认为这会削弱大英帝国，它的商业、贸易以及所有这些。但纳尔逊从未积极反对废奴主义。
We don't want free black men and women as citizens among us. Get rid, send them to Africa. And actually, a lot of abolitionists and a lot of black people themselves hate this colonization society because they see it as, I mean, they see it as unambiguously racist. As for abolitionism,
弗朗西斯·斯科特·基做到了。作为19世纪30年代华盛顿特区的地区检察官，他是废奴主义的不懈敌人。他针对一位反奴隶制活动家提起了一起诽谤诉讼，那个人曾说，你知道，在这个城镇里，黑人没有正义。基基本上用这起诽谤诉讼把他赶走了。最著名的是，他起诉了一个住在乔治城的纽约人，仅仅因为他有一箱反奴隶制的小册子。基指控他煽动性诽谤，煽动奴隶和黑人反抗。他试图把这个案件变成一个巨大的政治样板戏。
Key is not a fan of abolitionism at all. So you mentioned Nelson. We talked about Nelson and slavery. Nelson's not a fan of abolitionism, but I don't think it's something that's on his mind very much. He's not a fan of it because he thinks it will weaken the British Empire, its commerce, its trade, and all of this. But Nelson never actively campaigns against abolitionism.
我想是因为他想利用它来提升自己的政治生涯。他在结束语中说，先生们，你们愿意放弃你们的国家，允许它被废奴主义者夺走并占据吗？根据他们的品味，他们喜欢与黑人交往和融合。无论如何，他输掉了这个案子。实际上，那个家伙无罪释放了，他最终受到了羞辱，他的政治野心也破灭了。
Francis Scott Key does. As District Attorney for Washington, D.C. in the 1830s, he is a tireless foe of abolitionism. He brings a libel case against one anti-slavery activist, a guy who had said, you know, there's no justice for black people in this town. Key basically drove him out with this libel case. Most famously, he prosecuted a guy from New York who was living in Georgetown merely for having a trunk full of anti-slavery tracts. Key accused him of seditious libel and inciting slaves and blacks to revolt. And he tried to turn this case into a massive political set piece.
所以当你把这一点与1812年战争的背景问题放在一起时，我认为它实际上变得越来越合理了。它是如何区分奴隶和雇佣兵的？雇佣兵可能是合作者，有偿的合作者。好的，所以是白人合作者。所以《国家》杂志，一份非常自由的期刊。“基对为自由而战的黑人的信息是明确的。我们将追捕你们，搜捕会让你们感到恐惧，因为当我们找到你们时，
I think because he wanted to use it to boost his own political career. Are you willing, gentlemen, he said in his closing speech, to abandon your country, to permit it to be taken from you and occupied by the abolitionist, according to whose taste it is to associate and amalgamate with the Negro. Anyway, he lost this case. Actually, the bloat went free, and he ended up humiliated and his political ambitions were punctured.
你们的下一站就是坟墓的阴霾。”所以这是许多自由派作家对21世纪的看法。我的意思是，我认为有足够的模糊性，让听众自己做决定。所以有些人可能会拒绝所有这些，说，不，不，不，他显然只是在谈论使用美国革命的修辞或类似的东西。我的意思是，我想这听起来像是一个对奴隶制和自由思考很多的人。我想它有很多不同的含义。通常，特别是在美国，这些含义往往彼此直接冲突。所以也许他无法解决这些模糊性。
So when you put that alongside the issue of the context of the War of 1812, I think it is actually, it becomes more and more plausible. How is it distinguishing between the slave and the hireling? The hiring could be collaborators, paid collaborators. Okay, so white collaborators. So the Nation magazine, a very liberal journal. Key's message to the blacks fighting for freedom was unmistakable. We will hunt you down and the search will leave you in terror because when we find you,
这实际上是一个非常公正的裁决。无论如何，回到歌曲本身。显然，它在1812年战争中引起了共鸣，之后它从未真正淡出人们的视线。所以有一位日记作者乔治·坦普尔顿·斯特朗的记录，他在1837年写关于纽约市的情况。很多醉醺醺的游手好闲的人正走过，
your next stop is the gloom of the grave. So this is the 21st century take by a lot of kind of liberal writers. I mean, I think there's enough ambiguity, though, for listeners to make up their own minds. So some people may reject all of this and say, no, no, no, he's obviously just talking about using the rhetoric of the American Revolution or something. I mean, I suppose that it sounds like this is a man who thinks a lot about slavery and liberty. And I guess it has many different shades of meaning. Often, particularly in America, those shades of meaning are in direct conflict with each other. So perhaps he couldn't resolve those ambiguities.
声嘶力竭地尖叫着《星条旗》，伴随着各种地狱般的噪音。但它听起来很光荣。这是一个光荣的事情，无论歌词和音乐如何被糟蹋。我的意思是，它经常被糟蹋，不是吗？因为它太难唱了。
And that's a very fair-minded verdict, actually. Anyway, back to the song itself. Obviously, it strikes a chord in the War of 1812, and it never really fades from view afterwards. So there's an account from a diarist, George Templeton Strong, is writing about New York City in 1837. A lot of tipsy loafers are just going past,
完全正确，它被糟蹋了。它也被糟蹋了，因为在这一点上，人们经常改变歌词。所以人们会在7月4日的庆祝活动等场合播放这首歌，它足够出名，人们开始模仿它并制作政治变体。所以有一个禁酒版本，在19世纪中期非常流行。“哦，谁没有在黎明的第一道曙光中看到，一些可怜的臃肿的酒鬼摇摇晃晃地回到家。”
screaming out the star-spangled banner at the top of their lungs and in all sorts of diabolical discords. But it sounds gloriously. It's a glorious thing altogether. the words and music no matter how it's mangled. I mean, it often is mangled though, isn't it? Because it's so difficult to sing.
那会成为一首很棒的国歌。内战双方都声称拥有它。这真的很有趣。所以邦联当然有他们自己的旗帜。他们不会庆祝《星条旗》。或者他们会吗？因为他们视他为自己人。马里兰州的人，这是一个边境州。
Exactly, it is mangled. It's also mangled because at this point, people are often changing the words. So people would play the song at Fourth of July celebrations and things, and it was well known enough for people to start parodying it and to produce political variations. So there's a temperance version, very popular in the mid-19th century. Oh, who has not seen by the dawn's early light, some poor bloated drunkard to his home weekly reeling.
一个奴隶主？《里士满审查员》，1861年。“让我们永远不要向北方投降，那首高贵的歌曲，《星条旗》。它在起源和情感上，在诗歌和歌曲上都是南方的。”好吧，那他们就不应该废除那面旗帜。但他们确实有他们自己的星条旗。我想他们有，是的。
That would make a great anthem. Both sides in the Civil War claim it. That's really interesting. So the Confederates have their own flag, of course. They're not going to celebrate the Star-Spangled banner. Or are they? Because they see him as one of their own. A man of Maryland, which is a border state.
但不是《星条旗》。不是那个，不。但它仍然不是国歌。19世纪末，它开始变得更加正式，更加制度化。美国海军学院在1889年升降旗时开始在早晚播放它。
A slaveholder? The Richmond Examiner, 1861. Let us never surrender to the north, the noble song, the Star-Spangled banner. It is Southern in origin and sentiments in poetry and song. Well, they shouldn't have abolished the flag then. But they do have a star spangled banner of their own. I suppose they do, yes.
1892年，南达科他州米德堡的指挥官下令在撤退时播放它。他告诉州长，州长说，哦，多么绝妙的主意。我会让州民兵在我们，你知道，在撤退时播放它。他告诉战争部长。战争部长说，哦，我喜欢那个主意。让我们让每个陆军哨所每天晚上都播放它。而旗帜本身到这一点也成为了一件神圣的遗物。所以它留在了那个堡垒指挥官阿米斯特德的家族中。而旗帜本身，到这一点。而旗帜本身，到这一点，也成为了一件神圣的遗物。所以它留在了家族中。这是大的一面，不是真正被射击的那一面。
But not the star spangled banner. Not the, no. But it's still not the national anthem. Towards the end of the 19th century, it starts to become a little bit more formalized, a bit more institutionalized. The U.S. Naval Academy starts playing it morning and evening in 1889 when they raise and lower the flag.
不，这是巨大的一面。巨大的一面如此破旧的一个原因是家族会把碎片送给朋友。他们会说，你想要一块来自那首歌的《星条旗》吗？所以旗帜最终有很多洞。事实上，史密森尼学会在1907年拿到这面旗帜时，试图买回一些洞。哦，所以他们没有把它归咎于红衫军。好吧，我相信他们确实把它归咎于红衫军。无论如何，第一次世界大战期间爱国主义高涨。
In 1892, the commander of Fort Meade, in South Dakota, orders that it's played at the retreat. He tells the state governor, the state governor says, oh, what a brilliant idea. I'll get the state militia to play it whenever we, you know, at the retreat and whatnot. He tells the secretary of war. The secretary of war says, oh, I love that idea. Let's get every army post to play it every evening. And the flag itself by this point is becoming a sacred relic too. So it stayed in the family of the bloke who was the commander of the fort, Armistead. And the flag itself, by this. And the flag itself, by this point, is becoming a secret relic, too. So it stayed in the family. This is the big one, not the one that actually got shot at.
1916年，伍德罗·威尔逊，我们当然在我们的三K党剧集中谈论过他，另一个南方人，也许并非巧合，他指示在所有军事场合播放它。不过，此时有一个复杂之处，没有标准的编排。所以威尔逊让美国教育部整理了一个。他们找了一系列专家。其中之一是一位相当著名的美国作曲家约翰·菲利普·苏萨，他们得到了一个基本上政府批准的版本。我能问一下，我们是否知道在19世纪和这一点之前，
No, this is the huge one. And one reason the huge one is so battered is because the family would give away pieces to friends. They would say, would you like a piece of the Star-Spangled banner from the song? And so the flag ends up having lots of holes in it. And actually the Smithsonian, when it got hold of the flag in 1907, tried to buy back some of the holes. Oh, so they didn't blame it on the red coats. Well, I'm sure they did blame it on the red coats. Anyway, then there's a huge upsurge of patriotism during the First World War.
是否有人对“雇佣兵和奴隶”的评论提出异议，还是他们只是没有注意它？我不认为人们非常注意它，尤其是因为，正如我们稍后将看到的，有一个竞争的废奴主义版本。对，好的。他们有抱怨。我们一会儿就会看到。
In 1916, Woodrow Wilson, we talked about him in our Ku Klux Klan episodes, of course, another Southerner, perhaps not coincidentally, he directs that has played at all military occasions. One complication, though, at this point, there is no standard arrangement. So Wilson gets the US Bureau of Education to sort one out. They get a series of experts. One of them is a quite famous American composer, John Philip Sousa, and they get a basically government-approved version. Can I just ask, do we know whether over the 19th century and up to this point,
人们对把它作为国歌有很多反对意见，但那不是主要的反对意见。在我们谈论它如何成为国歌之前，还有一个快速的侧记。到1910年代末，它已经在棒球比赛中播放了。所以它第一次在1918年的世界大赛中在卡米斯基公园播放。芝加哥小熊队正在接待红袜队。在第一场比赛中，一支军乐队演奏了这首歌，
whether any eyebrows are raised over that the Hiling and Slave comment, or do they just not paying the attention to it? I don't think people massively pay attention to it, and not least because, as we will see later, there is a rival abolitionist version. Right, okay. They have complaints. We were seeing just a sec.
尽管此时它还不是国歌。我们在11月在洛杉矶的棒球比赛中听到它播放，不是吗？我们确实听到了，是的。而且非常，非常令人兴奋。非常动人，是的。是的，完全正确。但在第一次世界大战结束时，美国仍然没有国歌。这可能是一个谈论国歌的好时机。
People have a lot of objections to this as the anthem, but that is not one of the principal ones. And just one quick side note before we talk about how it becomes an anthem. It's already being played by the end of the 1910s at baseball. So it's first played at the World Series in 1918, at Kamiski Park. The Chicago Cubs were hosting the Red Sox. And a game won, a military band played this song,
这是一个如此复杂的话题，多米尼克。这是一个非常复杂的话题。现在，我们在做法国大革命系列时做了我们的第一集国歌。你带我们了解了《马赛曲》的历史。是的。它有时被描述为世界上第一首国歌，尽管它有点，它竞争，不是吗，与我们下一集的主题，即《天佑国王》。
though it's not at this point the national anthem. And we heard it being played at a baseball game, didn't we, in November, in L.A. We did indeed, yeah. And very, very exciting it was, too. Very stirring, yeah. Yes, exactly. But at the end of the First World War, the United States still does not have a national anthem. And this is probably a good point to just talk for a second about national anthems more generally.
所以在关于《马赛曲》的那一集中，我确实把它描述为世界上第一首国歌，但我现在已经忏悔了那个观点，正如我们将在下一集关于《天佑国王》中讨论的那样。《马赛曲》是第一首国家歌曲，但不是第一首国歌。那些觉得这很有趣和迷人的人，请收听下一集。
Such a complicated topic, Dominique. It is a massively complicated topic. Now, we did our first national anthem episode back when we did a series on the French Revolution. And you took us through the history of the Marseillaise. Yes. which is sometimes described as the world's first national anthem, though it's sort of, it competes, doesn't it, with the subject of our next episode, which is God Save the King.
因为我们拥有一切。所以20世纪初，大多数国家没有国歌。确实有的国家往往是最近才发明的国家。所以主要是拉丁美洲国家，阿根廷有一个，巴西有一个，正如我们将发现的那样。
So in that episode on the Marseillaise, I did describe it as the world's first national anthem, but I have now repented of that opinion, as we will be discussing in our next episode on God Save the King. The Marseillaise is the first national song, but not the first national anthem. And people who find that intriguing and fascinating, do tune into the next episode.
秘鲁有一个。但在欧洲，它们被认为有点俗气，有点噱头。而且通常有国歌的国家，除了英国和法国，往往是像比利时或意大利这样拼凑的国家，
because we've got it all. So at the early 20th century, most countries don't have a national anthem. The countries that do tend to be countries that have recently been invented. So Latin American countries above all, Argentina has one, Brazil has one, as we will find out.
不得不为自己发明身份的国家。但在20世纪20年代，你有很多采用国歌的新国家。美国不想被落下。又有一位来自马里兰州的国会议员，也就是弗朗西斯·斯科特·基的家乡，名叫约翰·查尔斯·林萨科姆。他一次又一次地提出法案
Peru has one. But in Europe, they're seen as a bit tawdry, a bit gimmicky by and large. And often the countries with national anthems, Britain and France aside, tend to be made-up countries like Belgium or Italy,
让这首热门歌曲成为国歌，但他一直失败。他一直失败的原因不是因为“雇佣兵和奴隶”这些词，而是因为A，有些人说它是一个英国旋律。为什么我们要把英国旋律作为我们的国歌？是的，为什么我们要把英语作为我们的？是的，完全正确。
countries that have had to invent an identity for themselves. But in the 1920s, you've got a lot of new countries that are adopting anthems. The United States doesn't want to be left out. There's a congressman again from Maryland, so Francis Scott Key's home state, called John Charles Lynthacom. And he introduces a bill again and again
好吧，这是美国人可能想要反思的事情。和平主义者，当然第一次世界大战后有很多和平主义者，不喜欢它，因为它赞美战争。所以这是一件大事。而最大的反对意见是音乐上的。你已经提到了这一点。人们说它太高了。旋律很奇怪，无法演唱，为了深入探讨音乐学领域，
to make this hit the anthem, and he keeps losing. And the reason he keeps losing is not because of the words hireling and slave, it's because A, some people say it's a British melody. Why would we have a British melody as our national anthem? Yeah, why would we have the English languages are? Yes, exactly.
《星条旗》需要19个半音的音域，甚至一些专业歌手也无法达到那个音域。多米尼克，那到底是什么意思？19个半音。好吧，汤姆，如果“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的成员能够听到我在未来的奖励剧集中解释半音。我不能保证它会立即出现，但有一天，在这个播客结束之前，
Well, that's something on which American this has might care to reflect. Pacifists, and of course there are a lot of pacifists in the wake of the First World War, don't like it because it celebrates war. So that's a big thing. And the biggest objection is musical. You've already mentioned this. People say it is just too high. The melody is weird, it's unsingable, and to delve for a moment into the world of musicology,
我无疑会做一个关于这个主题的奖励剧集。那是人们可以期待的事情。是的，绝对。事实上，一些评论家把所有这些反对意见结合在一起。所以有一位基督教科学家名叫奥古斯塔·艾玛·斯特森。那是一个伟大的名字。斯特森夫人。
the Star-Spangled banner demands a range of 19 semitones, and even some professional singers are not capable of that range. And Dominic, what exactly does that mean? 19-semitate. Well, Tom, if members of the Restus History Club will be able to hear me explaining Semi-tones in a future bonus episode. I can't promise it it will come immediately, but one day, before the end of this podcast,
1922年6月，在《纽约论坛报》上刊登了一则巨大的广告，标题是“《星条旗》永远不可能成为我们的国歌”。她说它那暴力、无法演唱的节奏永远无法表达国家所基于的精神理想。国会从未，也永远不会。使一首源于人类情感最低品质的国歌合法化。上帝禁止它。令人惊讶的是，所有那些“雇佣兵和奴隶”的东西甚至没有进入这里的等式。
I will undoubtedly be doing a bonus episode on this very subject. That is something for people to look forward to. Yeah, definitely. And actually, some of the critics combine all those in one, all those objections. So there's a Christian scientist called Augusta Emma Stetson. That's a great name. And Mrs. Stetson.
不，一点也没有。她甚至没有提到这一点。现在的问题是，他们不必选择这个。还有其他选择。在整个19世纪，可能领先的候选人是另一首歌，《向哥伦比亚致敬》。《向哥伦比亚致敬》是为华盛顿1790年作为总统的第一次就职典礼而创作的。所以有那个，但到20世纪它已经有点衰落了。所以它不会赢。
In June 1922, took out a massive advert in the New York Tribune with the headline, the Star-Spangled Banner can never become our national anthem. And she says it has its violent, unsingable cadences can never express the spiritual ideals upon which the nation was based. Never has Congress and never will Congress. Legalize an anthem which sprang from the lowest qualities of human sentiment. God forbids it. It's amazing that all that the Highlands Save stuff isn't even entering the equation here.
然后到20世纪20年代，另一个大竞争对手是《美丽的亚美利加》。这是由一位名叫凯瑟琳·李·贝茨的英语文学教授写的。她在19世纪90年代，1893年去科罗拉多旅行。她写了这首对美国风景的赞美诗。如果你看《美丽的亚美利加》的歌词，它在美国以外不太出名，但美国人喜欢它。它相当通用和空洞，你知道的。是的，19世纪末有一种对那种国歌的狂热，不是吗？是的，确实有。
No, not at all. And she doesn't even mention that. Now the thing is, they don't have to choose this. There are alternatives. All through the 19th century, probably the leading candidate had been another song, Hale Columbia. Hale Columbia had been composed for Washington's first inaugural as president in 1790. So there's that, but that's gone into decline a bit by the 20th century. So that's not going to win.
它们实际上都是那样的。我的意思是，我们几周后会谈到巴西。它们太南非了。是的。它们非常通用，很多这些国歌。无论如何，《美丽的亚美利加》，一直非常受欢迎。在20世纪60年代，废除《星条旗》并改用《美丽的亚美利加》的支持声浪相当大。
Then by the 1920s, the other big rival is America the Beautiful. And this was written by an English literature professor called Catherine Lee Bates. She went on a trip to Colorado in the 1890s, 1893. She wrote this hymn of praise to the American landscape. If you look at the lyrics of America, the beautiful, it's not very well known outside America, but Americans love it. It's quite generic and waffly, which is, you know. Yeah, there's a kind of craze for those kind of anthems in the late 90th century, isn't there? Yes, there is.
到了1920年代，另一个强劲的竞争对手是《美丽的亚美利加》。这首歌是由一位名叫凯瑟琳·李·贝茨的英国文学教授创作的。她在19世纪90年代，即1893年去科罗拉多州旅行时，写下了这首赞美美国风景的赞美诗。如果你看看《美丽的亚美利加》的歌词，它在美国以外的地方不太出名，但美国人很喜欢它。它相当笼统且有些空洞，你知道的。是的，19世纪末人们对这类国歌有一种狂热，不是吗？确实如此。
They're all like that, actually. When you look at, I mean, we get to Brazil in a couple of weeks. They're so South Africa. Yeah. They're very kind of generic, a lot of these anthems. Anyway, America the Beautiful, consistently very popular. In the 1960s, there was quite a groundswell of support for scrapping the Star-Spangled Banner and having America the Beautiful instead.
其实它们都是那样的。我的意思是，几周后我们会谈到巴西。还有南非。是的，这些国歌中有很多都非常笼统。总之，《美丽的亚美利加》一直非常受欢迎。在20世纪60年代，曾出现过一股相当大的支持浪潮，要求废除《星条旗》，改用《美丽的亚美利加》。
And people have always said, it's easier to sing, it's a better tune, you can do more fun things with it, we've got the wrong anthem. Anyway, America the Beautiful didn't win. The Star Spangled Banner won precisely because of its military associations. So the lobby group, the veterans of foreign wars, organized a petition. They got 5 million names. Congress approved it. And President Herbert Hoover in 1931 signed it into law.
人们总是说，这首歌更容易唱，旋律更好，能玩出更多花样，我们选错了国歌。总之，《美丽的亚美利加》没能胜出。《星条旗》之所以胜出，正是因为它与军队的渊源。于是，游说团体——海外战争退伍军人协会组织了一次请愿。他们收集了500万个签名。国会批准了，赫伯特·胡佛总统在1931年将其签署为法律。
But it has never not been controversial. And obviously in the post-war years, post-Second World War, the controversies were about interpretations of the anthem. So I already mentioned some of them. At the 1968 World Series, Jose Feliciano, a Puerto Rican singer and guitarist, played it. He did a kind of Latin jazz, slightly folky kind of interpretation, and people said, it's terribly disrespectful, it's awful, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. And the disrespect is because the same reverence that Americans display towards the flag
但它从未停止过争议。显然，在战后，即第二次世界大战后，争议主要围绕着对国歌的解读。我已经提到过其中一些。在1968年的世界大赛上，波多黎各歌手兼吉他手何塞·费利西亚诺演唱了这首歌。他用了一种拉丁爵士、略带民谣风格的演绎方式，人们说这极其不尊重，太糟糕了，等等等等。这种不尊重感是因为美国人对国旗所表现出的那种崇敬
is now being applied towards the anthem. Is that right? Yeah, and that's something that actually, I think Americans, some of our Americanists may not realize, that not all countries have the same attitude to their national anthem. So, for example, in Britain, I think it's fair to say that God save the king, made most people kind of laugh when they hear God save the king. Or indeed, God save the Queen, which we will be discussing in our next episode. Exactly.
现在被应用到了国歌上。是这样吗？是的，我认为这一点，我们的一些美国研究者可能没有意识到，并非所有国家对国歌的态度都一样。例如，在英国，我认为可以公平地说，当大多数人听到《天佑国王》时，他们会觉得有点好笑。或者说《天佑女王》，我们将在下一集讨论。没错。
The interpretations of it are seen as completely valid and fair, and people have fun with it. It's not a sacred relic. Another controversial moment, of course, Jimmy Hendrix is, I was about to say Jimmy Carter. as guitar solo. That would be good money to see that. Yeah. People sitting there ripping off his cardigan. Cardigan with an acoustic guitar.
对它的解读被视为完全有效且公平的，人们乐在其中。它不是什么神圣的遗物。另一个充满争议的时刻，当然是吉米·亨德里克斯的……我刚才差点说成吉米·卡特……的吉他独奏。那场面一定很值钱。是的。人们坐在那儿，撕扯着他的开衫。穿着开衫弹木吉他。
It's surrounded by peanuts or people dressed as peanuts. I think it would be absolutely tremendous. Backing group of peanuts. Anyway, Jimmy Hendrix did his guitar solo at Woodstock, obviously in 1969. That was one of 60 renditions of the Star-Spangled banner that Hendricks gave in the late 60s. But he'd been in the army, hadn't he? So perhaps he could get away with it.
周围全是花生，或者打扮成花生的人。我觉得那会非常棒。伴舞团是花生。总之，吉米·亨德里克斯在1969年的伍德斯托克音乐节上进行了吉他独奏。那是亨德里克斯在60年代末演奏的60个版本的《星条旗》之一。但他以前在军队待过，不是吗？所以也许他可以这么做。
The issue there is, I think, as of 1968, in Jose Fliss. It's bound up with Vietnam. It's seen as, you know, disrespectful. Disrespectful to the flag. The Star Spangled Banner is playing at the Mexicans Olympics in 1968 when Tommy Smith and John Carlos do their famous black power salutes in the middle ceremony. My favorite controversy, I don't know if you're familiar with this one, Tom, came at a rodeo in Salem, Virginia in 2005.
我认为，1968年何塞·费利西亚诺那次的问题在于，它与越南战争紧密相连。它被视为不尊重。对国旗不尊重。《星条旗》在1968年墨西哥奥运会上播放时，汤米·史密斯和约翰·卡洛斯在颁奖仪式上行了著名的黑人权力致敬礼。我最喜欢的争议，不知道你熟不熟悉，汤姆，发生在2005年弗吉尼亚州塞勒姆的一次牛仔竞技表演上。
And the organizers of this rodeo had agreed to feature a visiting celebrity from the Republic of Kazakhstan in Central Asia. He prefaced his performance with the words with speech. We support your war of terror. May George Bush drink the blood of every single man, woman and child of Iraq. As I remember, that was greeted with applause and cheers, wasn't it? It was greeted with applause and cheers. And then to the usual tune, he sang the words,
这次牛仔竞技表演的组织者同意让一位来自中亚哈萨克斯坦共和国的客座名人表演。他用一段演讲作为表演的开场白。我们支持你们的恐怖战争。愿乔治·布什喝下伊拉克每一个男人、女人和孩子的血。我记得，那段话赢得了掌声和欢呼，对吧？确实赢得了掌声和欢呼。然后，他用通常的曲调唱道：
Kazakhstan is the greatest country in the world. All other countries are run by little girls. Kazakhstan, number one, exporter of potassium, other Central Asian countries have inferior potassium. And that was, of course, Sasha Baron Cohen playing Borat. And I think he knew exactly what he was doing. He'd done American history at Cambridge.
哈萨克斯坦是世界上最伟大的国家。所有其他国家都由小女孩管理。哈萨克斯坦，第一，钾肥出口国，其他中亚国家的钾肥都很劣质。那当然是萨莎·拜伦·科恩扮演的波拉特。我想他很清楚自己在做什么。他在剑桥学过美国史。
He actually wrote his thesis on the civil rights movement, and he had the same supervisor as supervisor of my PhD. Oh, really? He learned from the best, yeah. Yeah. So Borat, very controversial, but not the most controversial take on the Star-Spangled banner, right? I guess not.
他实际上写过关于民权运动的论文，而且他的导师和我博士学位的导师是同一个人。哦，真的吗？他师出名门啊。是的。所以波拉特，非常有争议，但还不是对《星条旗》最具争议的解读，对吧？我想不是。
an even more famous one that you alluded to at the start of this episode. Yeah, so this is in 2016. San Francisco 49ers are playing their third pre-season game. The quarterback, Colin Kaepernick, takes the knee during the anthem, and he says he wants to do it to protest police brutality towards African Americans. This kicks off this firestorm of argument. Capinick played out the season, but he then became a free agent at the end of the season and no team signed him, basically no team wanted to touch him. And he sued the NFL, but the case was settled out of court. And the whole gesture of the taking the knee obviously became a huge thing after George Floyd was killed in 2020. So people may remember British sisters may remember that Keir Stama. Yes, and Angela Rainer.
还有一个更著名的，你在本集开头提到的。是的，那是2016年。旧金山49人队正在进行第三场季前赛。四分卫科林·卡佩尼克在国歌响起时单膝下跪，他说他想以此抗议警察对非裔美国人的暴行。这引发了一场激烈的争论风暴。卡佩尼克打完了那个赛季，但在赛季末成为自由球员，没有球队签下他，基本上没有球队愿意碰他。他起诉了NFL，但案件庭外和解了。而单膝下跪的整个姿态在2020年乔治·弗洛伊德被杀后显然成了一件大事。所以人们可能记得，英国的姐妹们可能记得基尔·斯塔默。是的，还有安吉拉·雷纳。
And Angela Rana, they posted a photograph of themselves very solemnly taking the knee in Starmers' House of Commons office. And meanwhile, activists in the United States actually toppled the statue of Francis Scott Key in Golden Gate Park. So that statue had stood in Golden Gate Park, San Francisco, since 1887, and it has subsequently been replaced with 350 black steel figures that represent the Africans that were on the first slave ship to Virginia in 1619. And presumably that is because the controversy around the Star-Spangled banner has now expanded from the fact that it is simply the National Anthem of the Dinkley.
还有安吉拉·雷纳，他们发布了一张照片，照片中他们非常庄重地在斯塔默的下议院办公室里单膝下跪。与此同时，美国的活动人士推倒了金门公园里弗朗西斯·斯科特·基的雕像。那座雕像自1887年起就矗立在旧金山的金门公园里，后来被350个黑色钢制人物所取代，代表着1619年第一艘运往弗吉尼亚的奴隶船上的非洲人。大概是因为围绕《星条旗》的争议现在已经扩大了，不仅仅因为它只是美国的国歌，
United States, and that people are now more aware of the context in which it was written, I suppose. Yes, and I think if you are on the sort of, if you're on the left or if you're on the left of that particular argument, the sort of slightly reflex thing to say now is, oh, it's an anthem that glorifies slavery. And I think, as we've established, there is at least ambiguity there. I mean, I think it's actually, I think it's impossible to be, you know, no one knows what was in Francis Scott's head when he, when he wrote that. I mean, my personal view is, well, first of all, it's not my anthem. American listeners should not, you know, they can do what they like.
而且人们现在更了解它创作时的背景了，我想是这样。是的，我认为如果你站在那个特定争论的左翼，现在一种稍微反射性的说法是，哦，这是一首美化奴隶制的国歌。我认为，正如我们所确定的，这里至少存在模糊性。我的意思是，我认为实际上，没人知道弗朗西斯·斯科特·基在写那首歌时脑子里在想什么。我的个人观点是，首先，这不是我的国歌。美国听众不应该……他们可以做他们想做的事。
It's no business of ours, what anthem they have. I don't think it's entirely groundless to say that there's a slavery connection. We know that Keone slaves. We know that he was a very, very determined foe of abolitionism. And personally, I think his text probably is aimed at slaves who are trying to escape and are helping the British. However, I think we've generally always had the position on the show that you can separate the art from the artist. And I think this is actually quite a nice example because we've already mentioned how temperance activists wrote their own version of it.
他们唱什么国歌与我们无关。说它与奴隶制有关并非完全没有根据。我们知道基拥有奴隶。我们知道他是一个非常、非常坚定的废奴主义反对者。我个人认为，他的歌词很可能是针对那些试图逃跑并帮助英国人的奴隶。然而，我认为我们在节目中一直持有的立场是，你可以将艺术与艺术家分开。我认为这是一个很好的例子，因为我们已经提到过禁酒主义者是如何编写他们自己的版本的。
But so did abolitionists. So this is the irony. The very people that Francis Scott Key was trying to suppress actually wrote their own version of his anthem. It was in 1844. It was in the abolitionist newspaper The Liberator. and it was by an activist called E. A. Atley, and it ran as follows. O say do you hear at the dawn's early light, the shrieks of those bondsmen whose blood is now streaming from the merciless lash, while our banner in sight with its star's mocking freedom is fitfully gleaming.
废奴主义者也一样。这就是讽刺之处。弗朗西斯·斯科特·基试图压制的那些人，实际上编写了他们自己版本的国歌。那是在1844年。它发表在废奴主义报纸《解放者》上，作者是一位名叫E.A.阿特利的活动家，内容如下：哦，请告诉我，在黎明的第一缕曙光中，你是否听到了那些奴隶的尖叫声，他们的鲜血正从无情的鞭子下流淌，而我们的旗帜在眼前，那嘲弄自由的星星在闪烁。
Do you see the backs bear? Do you mark every score of the whip of the driver traced channels of gore? And say doth our star-spangled banner yet wave, O, the land of the free. and the home of the brave. So kind of bitterly ironic final lines. Now obviously I think it would be deranged to suggest that Americans might like to adopt that text rather than the one they have, but it's nevertheless worth bearing in mind that Key's text is not the only text of that anthem and that anthems often tell more than one story. And as we'll see in the rest of this series, even the most bombastic song can tell very surprising. and unexpected stories.
你看到那裸露的背了吗？你是否注意到了鞭子留下的每一道伤痕，那车夫留下的血迹斑斑的沟壑？请告诉我，我们的星条旗还在飘扬吗？哦，自由之地，勇士之家。这最后的几句真是苦涩而讽刺。显然，我认为如果有人建议美国人采用那样的歌词而不是现在的版本，那简直是疯了，但无论如何，值得记住的是，基的歌词并不是这首国歌唯一的歌词，国歌往往讲述不止一个故事。正如我们将在本系列其余部分看到的那样，即使是最浮夸的歌曲也能讲述非常令人惊讶和意想不到的故事。
And we'll be hearing one of those next time, won't we? We will, because we will be looking at God Save the King, the anthem of both England and Scotland, who have qualified for the World Cup finals. And the story of that song is actually framed by many of the same issues and controversies that we've been talking about with reference to the Star-Spangled Banner. And then after that, we will be looking at the German,
我们下次会听到其中一个，对吧？是的，因为我们将审视《天佑国王》，这首歌既是英格兰的国歌，也是苏格兰的国歌，他们都已经获得了世界杯决赛圈的资格。而这首歌的故事实际上是由我们讨论《星条旗》时提到的许多相同的问题和争议所构成的。在那之后，我们将审视德国、
the Dutch, the Brazilian and the South African national anthems. Members of the rest is history club, of course, can get immediate access to all of them. So if you like national anthems, I mean, this is your lucky day. National anthems, we've got them. But for now, Dominic, thanks so much for that. Goodbye, everyone. Bye-bye. Hello, everybody.
荷兰、巴西和南非的国歌。当然，Rest is History俱乐部的成员可以立即获得所有这些内容。所以如果你喜欢国歌，这意味着今天是你的幸运日。国歌，我们都有。但现在，多米尼克，非常感谢。再见，大家。再见。大家好。
Now, as those of you who are good children will know here in Britain on the 21st of June, it's Father's Day. just here in Britain. It's also Father's Day on 21st of June in the United States, in Canada, and in the Republic of Ireland. So those are four countries that are united by dads who love to listen to The Rest is History. And that is why we are offering an amazing 25% Father's Day discount on the subscription price to The Rest is History Club, because we are all. all heart. So treat the Peter the Great in your own life this Father's Day to early access to full series. You get early access, that you get that with a membership, you get bonus episodes,
现在，正如你们这些好孩子所知道的，在英国，6月21日是父亲节。仅仅是在英国。美国、加拿大和爱尔兰共和国的父亲节也是6月21日。所以这四个国家因为那些喜欢听《Rest is History》的爸爸们而团结在一起。这就是为什么我们为《Rest is History》俱乐部的订阅价格提供25%的父亲节折扣，因为我们全心全意。所以在这个父亲节，用提前观看完整系列的权限来款待你生命中的彼得大帝吧。你可以获得提前观看权，会员资格包含这些，你还可以获得额外剧集，
you get ad-free listening, you get access to tickets for live shows, basically you get an entire host of supplementary benefits. And that I think is what a lot of Patriarchs want, isn't it? It absolutely is because I think nothing says happy Father's Day quite like the chance to listen to six solid hours, ad free about the First World War. Yeah, that's what most fathers want. So head to the rest is history.com and click on the word gifts. And that gift, membership of our much loved Rest is History Club will land straight in your father's inbox on Father's Day itself. So if you want to give the best, Father's Day gift there's ever been in history, ever. And we say this as the presenters of the rest of history. You know what to do. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以享受无广告收听，获得现场演出门票，基本上你可以获得一系列补充福利。我想这就是许多家长想要的，不是吗？绝对是，因为我认为没有什么比能连续六小时无广告收听关于第一次世界大战的内容更能代表父亲节快乐了。是的，那是大多数父亲想要的。所以前往therestishistory.com并点击“礼物”一词。那份礼物，我们备受喜爱的Rest is History俱乐部的会员资格，将在父亲节当天直接发送到你父亲的收件箱中。所以如果你想送出历史上最好的父亲节礼物，有史以来最好的。我们作为《Rest is History》的主持人这么说。你知道该怎么做。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。